voilà chers collègues mesdames et
messieurs me sont rapporteurs notre
commission d'enquête chargé d'établir
les raisons de la perte de la
souveraineté d'indépendance énergétique
de la France a le plaisir aujourd'hui
d'accueillir les représentants des
organisations syndicales siège en sein
du comité social et économique central
def
j'informe les membres de notre
commission que le 25 janvier une autre
table ronde sera organisée avec les
syndicats des fédérations en charge du
secteur de l'énergie en complément de
l'audition du jour l'audition des
membres des organisations syndicales
notamment été souhaitées par Sébastien
Jumel membre du bureau de la commission
d'enquête mais les problématiques liées
à la gestion des personnels travaillant
dans le secteur de l'énergie en
particulier dans la filière nucléaire
ils enjeux connexes compétences carrière
etc ont été évoqués à plusieurs reprises
au cours des auditions que la Commission
d'ores et déjà organisée
personnelle technique comme chercheur ou
gestionnaire
je vous remercie donc Mesdames et
Messieurs d'avoir accepté de venir
présenter vos observations devant la
commission d'enquête
et particulièrement Monsieur page le
Mérour qui a bien accepté de bien qui a
accepté de bien vouloir jouer le
coordonnateur dans l'organisation de
cette table ronde je note que plusieurs
anciens présidents de DF vous ont rendu
hommage pour vos compétences pour votre
démo vous ment pour la façon aussi dont
les le dialogue s'organise dans
l'entreprise je n'igrainerai pas les
différentes questions que nous avons
avec eux évoqué plutôt je préférais vous
laisser
la liberté et le temps de présenter vos
propres observations et analyses
nous vous donnons ainsi à chacun une
on se disait qu'il y a un propos
liminaire de Monsieur le Secrétaire
général du CSE puis qu'ensuite on
rentrerait peut-être plutôt dans un
échange itératif on va rester assez
libre dans l'organisation du temps de
travail mais
l'important c'est que la parole circule
je crois néanmoins utile de préciser en
guise d'introduction que le comité dont
vous faites partie est un organe qui a
un accès exclusif à des informations
sociales et financières importantes
concernant EDF c'est le contenu dans la
base des données sociales économiques et
environnementale comme tout comité
central ce comité social et économique
et en vertu de la loi il peut notamment
faire appel à des experts s'il le
souhaite le public aurait donc tort de
voir ce comité comme un simple organe de
gestion d'avantage sociaux de
revendications c'est bien un organe de
pilotage de l'entreprise
c'est un organe qui est parti prenante
aux décisions susceptibles d'engager
l'avenir de la société au sein duquel il
a été créé il est consulté à cet effet
il dispose également d'un droit d'alerte
deux de ses membres sièges avec voix
consultatif au sein du conseil
d'administration d'EDF et il représente
plusieurs milliers de salariés j'ai noté
62000 on va en 2021 pour le groupe
contre 66 000 en 2017 selon plusieurs
documents publics d'EDF avant de vous
laisser la parole il me revient de vous
demander de bien vouloir prêter serment
de dire la vérité toute la vérité et
rien que la vérité en application de
l'ordonnance du 17 novembre 1958
relatives au fonctionnement des
assemblées parlementaires en conséquence
de quoi je vous inviter successivement à
bien vouloir à l'appel de votre nom on
va le faire comme ça levez la main
droite et dire je le jure donc c'est le
secrétaire Philippe page le mérou
madame Virginie de Meyer
Monsieur Arnaud Barlet
monsieur Julien Laplace
et Madame Catherine Nicolas Michon merci
beaucoup et bien monsieur
page
pardon je vous laisse la parole
ben écoutez monsieur le Président sur le
rapporteur madame monsieur député merci
de nous accueillir et merci d'avoir bien
voulu entendre prendre en compte notre
contribution dans cette commission
d'enquête dont l'objet non seulement
légitime mais nous intéresse au plus
haut point puisque c'est depuis cela
fait des années maintenant que cette
question là est centrale pour beaucoup
de nos travaux alors c'est avec un
esprit de grande responsabilité que nous
sommes devant vous dans une période qui
est très chargée mais pour nous vous
l'imaginez pour d'autres raisons ceci
dit nous avons considéré évidemment
qu'il fallait participer pleinement à
vos travaux
la question de la souveraineté
énergétique
nous alerte depuis de nombreuses années
et selon les travaux auxquels on va
faire référence au long de cette
audition et d'ailleurs pour beaucoup
d'entre nous voulons à disposition
ne sont rien dues à la fatalité c'est à
dire que nous sommes face à une
situation de maintenant depuis plusieurs
années qui s'est dégradé petit à petit
mais surtout quand on parle de
souveraineté énergétique pour nous on
parle de deux choses qui sont très
importantes pour nos concitoyens les
collectivités locales des entreprises
c'est à la fois la sécurité
d'approvisionnement et le tarif de
l'électricité et c'est de ces deux
points majeurs que l'électricité de
France a pu gérer durant des décennies
du temps d'un monopole public ce sont
petit à petit ventilés si j'ose dire
ensuite des adoptions des directives
vers un certain nombre de lois
ainsi alors que nous avions deux poutres
essentielles qui tenaient notre service
public la loi de nationalisation de 1946
puis le plan Messmer de 73 74 nous
avions des atouts formidables par
l'hydroélectricité notamment à partir de
46 et par le nucléaire en Suisse pour
tenir
cette souverain énergétique avec ces
deux pendant sécurité
d'approvisionnement et maîtrise et
maîtrise des tarifs or il se trouve que
je le disais pas de fatalité mais non
pas de fatalité qu'est-ce qui est arrivé
à la France sur cette question là bien
une maladie grave qui s'appelle l'appât
du gain qui finalement plonge l'humanité
dans le noir petit à petit également et
en s’est aperçu que le phénomène de
déresponsabilisation était
au centre de tout ce qu'il fallait en
réalité protéger
alors il y avait un slogan qui était un
slogan syndical à l'époque des premières
directives qui étaient claire qui était
l'électricité n'est pas une marchandise
et aujourd'hui il faut vraiment le
reprendre au pied de la lettre
l'électricité n'est pas une marchandise
effectivement à partir du moment où on a
confié l'électricité au marché et bien
le marché il a fait son boulot peut-on
même de lui reprocher c'est une question
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait l'électricité il
a l'air rendu l'électricité le marché de
la rendue électricité rare et cher et en
fin de compte on est dans un dans un
arbre des causes de la perte de
souveraineté qui fait qu'il y a personne
n'est responsable de rien et c'est le
grand malheur c'est que personne n'est
plus responsable en tout cas du service
public de l'électricité en France c'est
à dire que les directives ont
exigé de la France la séparation des
activités de production de transport et
de distribution d'électricité on s'est
retrouvé donc dans des situations tout à
fait ubuesque
allant jusqu'à avoir des avis divergents
entre RTE et EDF sur le maintien de la
centrale de Fessenheim par exemple enfin
des choses complètement aberrantes parce
que chacun gère en boutiquier ça
sacrénerie c'est à dire que plus
personne dans la vision de long terme et
la vision surtout de l'intérêt national
de faire en sorte que ce produit qui est
un produit de première nécessité et non
stockable c'est important de le dire et
non stockable doit être géré en
permanence à l'instant T avec une
équation qui relève d'une bonne classe
de CM2 mais finalement on aura dû donner
à réfléchir l'avenir de l'électricité à
une classe de CM2 plutôt commerciaux
européen puisque il y a une équation qui
est simple et c'est les doigts de la
physique qui prennent le pas là sur les
lois du marché c'est le fameux P égal c
la production en tout temps doit égaler
à la consommation et dans le égal vous
avez le 50 Hertz qui est la fréquence et
si on perce 50 Hertz effectivement on
perd le réseau
pour couvrir ce fameux P c'est assez
simple c'est pour ça que vraiment ça ça
relève d'un niveau scolaire tranquille
il faut être certain d'avoir tout le
temps une capacité de moyens pilotable
on va redéfinir tranquillement les
choses mais vous vous l'avez en tête il
faut avoir une somme de moyen pilotable
de production qui soit égal en tout
temps
360 jours et nuit par an au pic
potentiel de consommation d'électricité
en France donc c'est assez simple c'est
assez simple il faut additionner les
moyens nucléaires les moyens
hydrauliques et les moyens thermiques
pilotables donc pour pouvoir tout le
temps en tout temps assurer les besoins
en électricité en France avec un pic
hivernal qui aujourd'hui donc n'est plus
couvert alors pilotable nous on est à
l'aise avec ce mot puisqu'on en est les
inventeurs au CCE avant le CSEC et on
l'a mis sur la place publique
en 2016 et on a dès 2017
nous vous remettre tous les documents
lancer les premières alertes sur les
potentialités malheureuses d'avoir un
hiver qui serait interrompu ou en tout
cas où on aurait des problèmes de
chauffage ou d'éclairage et 2017 c'est
notre première alerte sur sur le sujet
avec une conférence de presse reprise
plus ou moins et ensuite depuis tous les
hivers en entrée d'hiver nous avons
assisté sur ce point à tel point
d'ailleurs que désormais l'entreprise
elle-même en fait un point récurrent de
nos séances de CSE Centro à l'automne
avec ce qui nous permet d'avoir un débat
contradictoire entre la vie de
l'entreprise et puis nos travaux
d'expertise qui sont solides conséquent
et reconnu en la matière donc nous
sommes dans une situation effectivement
nous avons observé de façon tout à fait
mathématique la perte de 12 gigawatts de
capacités pilotables ces 10 dernières
années ça concerne évidemment pour la
centrale de Fessenheim mais ça concerne
également les centrales thermiques
d'Aramont de Porcheville du Havre et
donc des centrales qui étaient qui
certes ne fonctionnait pas chaque jour
mais qui était là pour sécuriser le
réseau à tout moment ces choix ont été
faits à
l'encontre du bon sens mais encore une
fois dans des dans des circonstances
différentes
le choix de la fermeture de Fessenheim
qui a été pour lequel l'ensemble des
organisations
représentatives au sein du CE à l'époque
on bien naviguer absolument négatif
plusieurs d'ailleurs
plus des expertises démontrant
l'aberration de cette fermeture alors
que tant économiquement que en matière
de sûreté ou d'environnement il y avait
aucun problème pour maintenir cette
centrale qui nous manque beaucoup
aujourd'hui qui demande beaucoup
aujourd'hui mais ça fait plaisir aux
Allemands puisqu'on leur rachète
l'électricité à prix d'or et les
centrales thermiques ont été fermées non
pas pour des raisons politiciennes de de
de basse
de basse en tant que politique je dirais
professionnel
pour ce qui est du Thermomix c'est une
politique de boutiquier qui a amené à ça
puisque EDF a considéré elle-même la
direction de DF contre la ville tous les
organisations syndicales à nouveau qu'il
fallait fermer les centrales d'Aramont
du Havre et de Porcheville parce que
elle coûtait trop cher en coût fixe on
pourra y revenir mais c'était de l'ordre
de 30 millions d'euros par an et comme
ça tournait pas assez ça valait pas le
coup mais ça c'est un raisonnement de
boutiquier et ça n'est pas un
raisonnement avec une vision nationale
puisque si on a à blackout ou même
régional des coupures importantes on
serait bien au dessus de 30 millions
d'euros par an notes d'ailleurs que
pour ce qui est du dernier marché de
capacité accorder à au centre combinégas
de landividurant Finistère le coût pour
la nation et le 40 millions d'euros par
an sans tourner sans tourner voilà mais
là on est plus sur le service public on
est sur sur total qui d'ailleurs fait
exploiter cela à Siemens par les
Allemands de l'entreprise allemande de
Siemens qui exploite tout ça comme ça la
boucle est bouclée entre la fermeture de
Fessenheim le père en grande difficulté
abandonnée par les Allemands et
finalement les Allemands c'est même si
les mains ce qui exploite leur division
il y a de quoi quand même se taper sur
les cuisses mais si c'était drôle et
donc tout cela nous amène à un certain
nombre de paradoxes c'est-à-dire qu'on a
depuis ces années de directives et de
alors abonder par la loi Nome qui est
venu organiser non plus la le marché de
l'électricité mais finalement le
transformer en trafic mafieux autorisant
toutes les dérives sur lesquelles nous
pourrons revenir
et nous avons pourtant
grâce au monopole public qui a permis
l'installation de moyens forts
d'infrastructures du pays en la matière
en matière d'électricité le réseau
les centrales hydrauliques les centrales
nucléaires tout cela a été construit du
temps de DF monopole publique et puis au
moment où la dette était en train de
plus que s'amortir et nous avons ici des
belles courbes à vous montrer et bien on
ouvre le capital et puis on dit
finalement ça va profiter aux copains
entre 2006 et 2009 la dette d'EDF a été
multipliée par 3
sans investissement ni sur le réseau ni
sur la production qu'elle soit
hydraulique ou nucléaire par 3 qu'est-ce
qui qu'est-ce qui s'est passé là encore
des responsabilisations c'est à dire que
finalement les directions de ces
nouvelles entreprises à capitaux ouverts
ce sont dit oh ben on va faire comme les
autres boîtes on va essayer de faire des
affaires
alors B l'étude de la dette qui fait
beaucoup causer aujourd'hui c'est normal
parce qu'elle est très inquiétante la
dette de DF aujourd'hui la dette de DF
elle est composée de trois tiers le
premier tiers c'est les aventures à
l'international de tous ces braves gens
qui sont venus les uns après les autres
diriger l'entreprise et qui ont fait des
paris parfois dignes du casino à
l'international faisant perdre des
milliards à des milliards d'euros à
l'entreprise et triste de France le
deuxième tiers il est dû à l'arène cette
loi abominable la loi nommée dont avec
42 euros qui fait qui fait travailler
les les salariés les agents d'EDF pour
la sous-traitance c'est votre dernière
question de votre liste de questions
m'en y reviendra et donc oui qui a de
quoi énervé effectivement puisque entre
ces un des seuls cas au monde où on voit
ça il y en a d'autres il y a d'autres il
y a un autre système économiques qui
fonctionnent comme ça je le disais c'est
la mafia et donc on a vu
s'opposer donc des entreprises qui au
lieu de converger en termes d'intérêt
par séparation ont eu des activités
différentes voire concurrentes on a vu
donc les énergies pilotables
opposées aux énergies renouvelables en
termes d'investissement c'est à dire que
là on a connu là c'était alors 2008 le
paquet de climat énergie européen
enrichi par celui de 2014 alors là on y
va on les gamelles c'est-à-dire que on
investit à fond dans les EnR en voiture
voilà c'est le jackpot d'ailleurs pour
certains en terme de rentes privées par
contre il s'est rien passé pendant ce
temps là on a éteint on n'a rien investi
sur nos moyens pilotables donc le
moratoire du nucléaire depuis la
centrale de Civaux téléguidé par par
l'Allemagne puisqu'en matière d'énergie
Bruxelles par le par l'Allemand il y a
qu'une seule langue c'est aussi un des
gros problèmes de la France et c'est ce
qui nous fait grand peine puisque les
deux atouts dont je parlais en en
introduction le service public et le
plan Brice mer qui nous avait permis
de maîtriser nos tarifs parce que la
souveraineté énergétique c'est pour
avoir la souveraineté économique c'est
l'énergie un tel levier et on le voit
aujourd'hui si on si on pouvait le
maîtriser et nous avons des propositions
à cet égard nous aurions finalement une
capacité à jouer sur à jouer sur
l'inflation donc et bien on a confié on
avait des atouts formidables donc ça a
duré une bonne vingtaine d'années et
puis quand le marché s'est installé les
premières directives 1996 puis 2002
alors là la fiesta à Barcelone avec
messieurs Chirac et Jospin qui vont
fêter la en tout cas démarrer inauguré
la l'étape finale de la marchandisation
du gaz électricité c'est comme ça que ça
s'appelle 2002 à Barcelone avec
messieurs hasnar Berlusconi et Blair
donc des gens connus pour leur
attachement service public bien
évidemment et donc là c'est le début
vraiment le début de la fin de la fin
j'allais dire alors maintenant il faut
consolider tout ça puisque là on a pu
voir les dettes continuent à exploser le
principe de sous-traitance
devenir galopant c'est à dire qu'on a
opposé de façon inconsidérée une
maîtrise une capacité technique
maîtrisée par un personnel formé attaché
à son entreprise qui qui s'investissait
dans ces métiers par un phénomène de
sous-traitance doublé depuis quelques
années par un phénomène de filialisation
bien au-delà du statut des
UG qui nous a amené finalement une perte
de compétences en interne qu'on a payé
très cher sur le chantier EPR et qu'on
continue de payer très cher qu'on paye
cher tous les jours sur nos
installations qu'elles soient nucléaires
ou autre et donc une perte de maîtrise
technique parce que on a voulu faire
comme les autres là aussi les dirigeants
gérés en boutiquier on était dans un
pays on avait plus besoin d'usine on
allait être une société de service donc
entre les gamins à l'école à qui on
invitait plus qu'on invitait plus à
aller vers les formations techniques et
à qui on disait vous serez au chaud dans
un bureau avec vue sur mer ou sur la
montagne enfin toutes les blagues qu'on
leur a raconté et aujourd'hui
la friche du tissu industriel français
c'est la facture de tout ça évidemment
c'est pas la fatalité à tout cela il y a
des responsables à chaque étape il y a
eu nombre de responsables qui jamais
n'ont écouté les organisations
syndicales qui se sont opposées à tous
ces phénomènes et quand je disais que le
marché avait fait son travail
c'est-à-dire a rendu l'électricité rare
et cher nous sommes aujourd'hui dans une
situation
d'impasse sauf à s'affranchir des règles
de marché c'est ce que nous avons
proposé alors dans les travaux que nous
allons vous remettre nous avons très
récemment donc un début décembre remis à
la craie une contribution
puisqu'il y avait une consultation
publique de la craie sur la nouvelle
tarification possible du TRV tarif
réglementé de vente d'électricité pardon
et donc là nous avons par nos travaux
c'est central depuis des années après le
droit d'alerte économique sur lequel on
pourra revenir si vous si vous le
souhaitez là nous avons
après de gros travaux avec notre cabinet
notre cabinet partenaire qui est sécafi
sur les questions économiques et nous
avons pu
on a eu l'honneur d'émettre des
propositions qui sont des propositions
d'urgence et nous vous invitons à les
regarder de très près parce que elle
vous permettrait en tant que
représentant de la nation de reprendre
la main et de vraiment parce que c'est
ce qu'il faut c'est il faut que vous
repreniez la main sur cette belle
entreprise nous on demande deux choses
très simples
à la craie c'est à dire 1 la suspension
de la reine qui est prévue dans un texte
de la République qui s'appelle le code
de l'énergie et qui nous dit en cas de
force majeure il faut suspendre l'arène
en tout cas on peut suspendre la reine
et nous on considère que quand on avait
comme il y a quelques semaines encore
50% des réacteurs au tapis c'est un cas
de force majeure quand il y a une guerre
en Europe c'est un cas de force majeure
et quand le prix de l'électricité est
vendu à 1000 euros alors qu'on ne
produit à moins de 100 c'est un cas de
force majeure donc ou alors on veut bien
aller chez Larousse ça peut faire un
stage de trois semaines donc on est
vraiment dans une situation comme on a
dit nous n'avons aussi un dico conseil
d'administration EDF qui nous a poliment
écouté mais à part les administrateurs
salariés personne n'a repris nos
propositions un en suspend la reine 2 on
calcule le TRV à partir de 9 mix de
production nationale voilà on demande à
déroger au marché européen en toute
urgence avec ces deux ces deux leviers
très simple l'arrivée c'est qu'on divise
par 3 le prix qui est proposé
aujourd'hui du TRV et qui est proposé
avec le bouclier sans toucher à la TVA
ce qui reste un levier pour l'état non
on s'occupe pas de la partie de la
partie fiscalité nous on est sur la
partie production c'est-à-dire ce qu'on
produit à combien on peut le vendre et
bien c'est très simple on est parti sur
le recommandé la Cour des comptes à peu
près 60 euros le megawattheure pour le
nucléaire on a pris l'hydraulique en
compte et on a pris les prix plafonnés
du renouvelable et bien quand on met
tout ça on voit qu'on peut faire des
choses alors on a une expression entre
nous à ce qui reprend la situation du
Portugal et de l'Espagne qui qui
alors certains diront oui mais eux c'est
parce que c'est une péninsule alors je
vois on vient d'apprendre que la que le
l'Espagne portugais était une péninsule
c'est marrant donc un ils sont
interconnectés contrairement à ce que
dit encore une ministre une éminente du
gouvernement il y a quelques jours et ça
fait des années des années que les
électrons circulent dans les deux sens à
la frontière et heureusement il faut que
ça continue ainsi et puis deuxièmement
si eux sont effectivement une péninsule
géographique nous nous sommes en îlot
nous sommes en îlot d'énergie
décarbonées c'est à dire que la France
avec ses atouts nucléaires à
hydrauliques est un îlot puisqu'il n'y a
pas de politique européenne de l'énergie
est un îlot des carboné production
d'électricité donc bien sûr que nous
devons avoir cette dérogation immédiate
pour les citoyens français pour
maîtriser l'inflation pour sauver les
collectivités locales pour sauver les
artisans et les entreprises qui
souffrent d'un tarif qu'ils n'ont pas à
payer d'électricité en France c'est un
véritable scandale cette affaire là
franchement
dans quel autre système économique à
part la mafia on voit un produit qui est
vendu 10 fois son prix en sachant que
nous on a travaillé depuis 1946 un
service public et assez filaire de
production qui ont qui sont des atouts
phénoménal pour le pays et aujourd'hui
au nom de règles trafiquées sur le
marché de l'électricité on fait souffrir
tout le pays vraiment faut que ça cesse
donc c'est pour ça qu'on a que nous
avons aussi réalisé ces rapports et que
nous les mettons à votre à votre
disposition alors moi je veux pas être
parce qu'après c'est on va passer à des
échanges mais je veux vraiment insister
sur sur le caractère bien commun de
l'électricité c'est tout ce que nous
défendons par nos affichages vers
l'externe depuis maintenant trois ans
avec la constitution du Conseil national
de l'énergie et nos campagnes et nos
campagnes de presse et je dois dire que
nous sommes rejoints et ça fait vraiment
plaisir par nombre de groupements d'élus
mais aussi des associations de
consommateurs tels que la cncv avec qui
nous travaillons très bien la fncca avec
qui nous travaillons très bien et
beaucoup aujourd'hui de collectivités
locales et de et de mère de petites
communes de moyennes ou d'agglomération
qui reprennent nos propositions parce
qu'on ne peut pas il y a plus aucun sens
si ce n'est si ce n'est de dire
c'est ça qui tiendra l'Europe et puis
vous rendez pas compte on peut pas
lâcher et on peut pas se disputer avec
les Allemands les Allemands on peut y
revenir mais ils nous ont baladé sur la
politique énergétique depuis
Maastricht on peut on peut le dire et
les dindons de la farce c'est qui c'est
c'est les Français et parmi les Français
il y a les agents d'EDF qui en plus
aujourd'hui travaillent à bas coût pour
la pour la concurrence ce qui est encore
un scandale dans scandale mais enfin
travailler produire à 42 euros
travaillant 3,8 dans les centrales
nucléaires pour sortir un produit à 42-0
qui est revendu par la concurrence à 500
balles vous m'excuserez mais il y a de
quoi pas être d'accord avec la reine
quand on est agent EDF et qu'on voit
spolier son entreprise
à ce niveau là donc voilà voilà en
liminaire le décor dans lequel nous
travaillons et je vous le disais les
expertises alors
sur les difficultés de d'équilibre
production consommation nous en avons
plusieurs synthèses on vous a pas amené
la Bible rassurez-vous mais des cas des
centaines sous forme de quatre pages
ceci dit si ça vous intéresse les
expertises complètes seront mises à
votre disposition
des synthèses en cas de pages sur les
sourciles et également sur les trois
filières sur le nucléaire sur le
thermique et sur l'hydraulique ça aussi
l'hydraulique c'est une question dans la
question savoir combien comment on va
conserver nos concessions hydrauliques
dans ce décor et comment on revient sur
la question de la souveraineté
énergétique parce que alors là les
concessions hydrauliques qui étaient qui
devaient être bradés donnés offerte à la
concurrence suite à Adil lamentable
entre le gouvernement de Monsieur
Hollande à l'époque et du mois sous la
présidence de Monsieur Hollande et
Bruxelles est totalement inacceptable et
c'est d'autant plus inacceptable qui a
aujourd'hui des éléments nouveaux à
commencer par une guerre en Europe a
commencé par tout ce qu'on a vu pendant
la crise covid c'est à dire comment on
maintenait notre industrie avec une
vraie souveraineté aujourd'hui on
entendrait pas que des actionnaires
privés donc par nature dont on ne
connaîtra ni les nationalités futures ni
les intentions futures pourraient être
propriétaire de concession de barrage
hydraulique en France et pourquoi pas
tant qu'on y est en amont des centrales
nucléaires qu'elle refroidissent donc ça
c'est absolument
impossible je dis un dernier mot c'est
EDF c'est vous savez toutes les EDF
maison-mère c'est toutes les activités
de production et de commercialisation
évidemment au sein du groupe il y a
également RTU le transport et enedis la
distribution donc nous on plaide pour
revenir à un service public digne de ce
nom et totalement intégré et puis au
sein d'EDF il y a aussi nos collègues
qui travaillent en outre-mer sur les
départements en tout cas qui sont gérés
par EDF c'est à dire la Guyane la
Réunion
la collectivité de
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon l'archipel de
Guadeloupe et la Martinique et que là
aussi il y a nécessité à renforcer le
service public je le dis parce qu'on a
une expertise en cours mais nous ne
pouvons pas vous en rendre destinataire
parce qu'elle n'est pas terminée et elle
doit se terminer en principe au mois de
mars donc si cela vous intéresse sur
l'état du réseau et des installations on
est en train de faire une expertise qui
va voir valeur aussi son pesant d'or
parce qu'il y a également beaucoup à
dire sur la situation également sociale
sur l'électricité en outre-mer
je vous remercie de votre attention et
désolé d'avoir peut-être été un peu long
en liminaire mais c'était pour planter
le décor
merci beaucoup pour tous ces éléments
déjà bien complet c'est vrai qu'on a pas
encore beaucoup parlé des outre-mer et
que ce sera un sujet que c'est un sujet
tout aussi important
j'aurai une première question vraiment
sur le social dans la discussion on a
beaucoup parlé
de
la perte de compétences de la filière
de problématique d'attractivité je sais
d'octobre dernier ça a été un des grands
sujets
des battus médiatiquement quel est un
peu votre point de vue sur sur ces
sujets là pas seulement du nucléaire de
façon large d'EDF même si on dans
l'esprit du grand public EDF ça arrive
souvent avec nucléaire
qui veut commencer
Nicolas Michon
un petit point global sur l'évolution
des effectifs d'EDF depuis les années
2000 il faut savoir que de passer des
pics établissements publics industriel
et commerciale associé anonyme changer
radicalement la manière de gérer les
effectifs de l'entreprise EDF est passé
sa en 2004 et comme toute bonne et ça
qui se respecte EDF a décidé d'optimiser
sa masse salariale traduction supprimer
des emplois pour plaire aux actionnaires
auxquels on a versé beaucoup de
dividendes actionnaires principales
l'état je rappelle et pour faire plaisir
aussi aux agences de notation dont nous
avons besoin pour avoir des bonnes notes
afin de pouvoir emprunter au pré des
banques donc pour vous donner quelques
éléments chiffrés
quand Monsieur Lévy arrive à EDF en 2014
EDF SA compte 70 000 salariés
à la fin
demanda de Monsieur Lévy donc fin 2021
EDF compte 60
000 salariés
on peut on peut dire grosso modo qu'on a
perdu 10000 salariés en 8 ans ce qui est
quand même assez vertigineux quand on y
pense cela n'a pas fait les gros titres
des journaux cela n'a pas fait ne s'est
pas fait via un plan un plan de
licenciement mais cela s'est fait
j'allais dire pas en douceur parce que
cette chute a été assez violente dans
plusieurs directions dont je vais vous
parler cela c'est fait on part des un
non renouvellement des départs des
salariés qui partaient à la retraite on
a eu une pyramide des âges vous savez
toutes les personnes qui ont construit
ce magnifique outil industriel qui est
EDF sont partis ces dernières années
beaucoup d'entre eux notamment dans le
parc de production sont partis à la
retraite et beaucoup d'entre eux n'ont
pas été remplacés c'est comme ça que les
suppressions de poste
sont arrivées et également par le biais
de réorganisation incessante de
direction et de services ou le but était
de supprimer les postes vacants voire de
supprimer un petit peu plus quand on
voyait une économie à à faire facilement
donc on se retrouve avec des directions
majoritairement les directions
commerciales et les directions supports
qui ont vu leurs effectifs fondre
la direction commerce est passée de
12000 salariés à 7000 salariés en effet
les clients sont partis sont partis chez
nos concurrents avec le succès qu'on
connaît donc il a fallu dégraisser entre
guillemets un peu violemment la
direction commerce et maintenant nos
clients reviennent ce qui nous fait très
plaisir donc on se retrouve confrontés à
quelques petits problèmes dont je vous
parlerai
les directions supports qui sont
validation direction immobilière
direction des achats des RH direction
financière direction communication tout
ce qui tertiaire ont vu aussi leurs
effectifs diminuer
significativement donc on se retrouve
avec ces directions qui perdent beaucoup
de personnel et côté production on se
retrouve aussi avec une perte de
compétences que nous n'avons pas réussi
à compenser qui nous manque cruellement
maintenant parce que les directions
production et je pense que mes collègues
vous en parleront ont vu leur ticket
d'embauche je l'ai voire conserver au
minimum donc c'est pour ça que nous nous
retrouvons maintenant dans cette
situation les conséquences sociales de
ces suppressions d'emplois sont
multiples et malheureusement négatif je
vous parlerai de deux conséquences
principales
l'augmentation de la charge de travail
des salariés d'EDF en effet ils ont dû
prendre en charge les activités qui
étaient faites par leurs collègues qui
sont partis à la retraite ou dont les
postes ont été supprimés et qui n'ont
pas été remplacés donc cette
augmentation de la charge de travail se
traduit par une hausse forte des heures
supplémentaires notamment dans le
domaine de la production de l'ingénierie
et puis pour nos collègues de la
direction commerce par un recours massif
à l'intérieur c'était déjà le cas avant
que les clients reviennent vers nous
mais alors là c'est encore accentué dans
les directions commerciales et puis dans
les directions supports qui ont besoin
de recours à l'intérim pour absorber les
pics de charge ou même pour vivre au
quotidien tellement on manque de
personnel dans certaines directions
deuxième conséquence
très très importante je vous dirai
pression stress RPS le CS central a fait
faire une expertise RPS avec un
questionnaire adressé à l'ensemble des
salariés nous avons eu de nombreux
retours et nous pourrons mettre à
disposition de la commission cette cette
expertise avec des résultats qui sont
tout à fait éclairants sur les
conditions de travail et la santé des
salariés qui travaillent à EDF enfin je
terminerai avec la situation actuelle
des effectifs suite au discours de
Belfort et la relance du nucléaire on
s'est dit enfin on voit la lumière au
bout du tunnel
EDF a annoncé des recrutements massifs
dans les années à venir ce dont nous
nous félicitons
EDF a embauché 1700 salariés en 2021 a
accueilli plus de 3500 alternants EDF
accueille 4000 alternants là en 2022 et
comme confiant de pouvoir de pouvoir
embaucher un maximum d'alternants à la
fin de leur cursus pour devenir nos
nouveaux collègues mais il y a quand
même un mais un mais à cette annonce qui
est pourtant positive EDF a pris la
décision
d'embaucher beaucoup de nos futurs
collègues directement dans ces filiales
et ce seront des collègues qui seront
embauchés avec un CDI de droit commun
assorti d'une convention SYNTEC cela
veut dire que nos collègues ne seront
pas embauchés au statut des IEG et ne
feront pas partie d'EDF maison-mère cela
pour nous pose vraiment un problème
fondamental parce que nous exigeons nous
que nos collègues fassent partie de
d'EDF maison mère pour pouvoir baigner
matin midi et soir dans nos valeurs dans
nos missions de service public qui sont
au cœur de toutes nos activités et bien
entendu pour attirer les salariés et
pour surtout les fidéliser il est
évidemment nécessaire qu'il soit au
statut des IEG et j'ajouterai que ce
n'est vraiment pas le moment de
fragiliser le statut des IEG notamment
en dézinguant notre système de retraite
parce que nous avons à fidéliser des
salariés importants pour la souveraineté
énergétique de notre pays ce sont les
salariés qui m'ont construire et
maintenir les nouveaux EPR que nous
mettrons en place et ce sont aussi les
salariés des filières d'innovation comme
le développement des SMS donc voilà
c'est un message fort que nous voulons
vous faire passer aussi le statut doit
être conservé pour les nouveaux salariés
et ils doivent être embauchés maison
mère EDF et pas dans des filiales
je relance la question si quelqu'un
d'autre veut rebondir vraiment sur j'ai
compris les effectifs et le dialogue
social
sur les compétences et sur
l'attractivité du métier enfin je crois
que c'est des
évidemment la filière globalement au
delà d'EDF a beaucoup souffert de
l'image qui a été véhiculée sur le
nucléaire et quand on a une perspective
de fermeture de tranches puisque c'est
la PPE encore qui existe aujourd'hui
prévoir encore la fermeture de 12
tranches nucléaires supplémentaires si
je dis pas de bêtises forcément c'est
difficile dans ces conditions d'attirer
des personnes qui vont avoir du mal à se
projeter toute une carrière dans
l'entreprise donc ça ça a été pénalisant
et même si aujourd'hui suite au discours
de Belfort il y a un nouvel élan qui a
été donné sur l'énergie nucléaire
contenu du temps de formation des jeunes
et puis globalement on est dans un
contexte industriel comme la définition
en France ou pendant plusieurs années on
a eu droit en quelque sorte à un
industrie bashing ce qui fait que les
jeunes aujourd'hui ont tendance à
s'orienter vers des filières plus
tertiaires ou mais pas dans le pas dans
la technique et donc les viviers de
recrutement sont assez faible et donc
sur nucléaire c'est forcément compliqué
par rapport à l'image de l'industrie
comme l'a dit Catherine il y a un
élément important et ça c'est c'est pour
moi fondamental que vous l'entendiez
c'est la durée parce que ce qui est
important au niveau des compétences dans
le nucléaire c'est la durée parce que
tout simplement pour construire une
centrale nucléaire enfin on le voit avec
l'exemple de flamant ville ça dépasse la
dizaine d'années c'est à dire que si
vous avez quelqu'un qui rentre dans
l'entreprise aujourd'hui il aura
l'expérience de la construction d'une
centrale nucléaire dans 15 ans
si cette personne part de l'entreprise
avant ses 15 ans en fait
il a pas apporté c'est les compétences
qu'il a développé ne sont pas
capitalisées et là on a vraiment des
pertes de compétences pour l'entreprise
de ça c'est vraiment un aspect
fondamental c'est pour ça qu'on parle de
la préservation de notre statut qu'on
parle du système de retraite parce que
ce système de retraite a un avantage
merveilleux c'est qu'il fidélise les
agents EDF de par le fait qu'on peut
bénéficier du système des de la retraite
des IEG après 15 ans d'ancienneté et ça
c'est fondamental parce que si vous ne
si dans l'énergie nucléaire c'est une
des spécificités de cette industrie en
fait à avoir des compétences sur un
temps long et le fait que vous pouvez
vivre une un cycle complet quand vous
construisez une centrale nucléaire en 15
ans et quelque part vous pouvez
capitaliser ses compétences seulement au
bout de cette dur là c'est pour ça que
c'est
quelque chose que vous vous trouvez pas
forcément dans une autre industrie pour
construire un si vous construisez une
voiture la voiture est développée en
deux trois ans mise en commercialisation
et vous avez quelque part un retour
d'investissement sur les compétences
beaucoup plus court le nucléaire on est
sur une autre échelle de temps et c'est
pour ça que c'est cette dimension là est
fondamentale
[Musique]
en complément
des difficultés qui a amené cette perte
de compétences c'est la gestion en stop
and go ce qu'on appelle stop and go
la filière nucléaire mais pas que
globalement la pyramide des âges EDF
essa il y a tous les gens qui ont
construit le parc nucléaire après vous
avez les embauches avec la loi sur les
35 heures jusqu'en 2002 et après il y a
eu un stop complet des embauches à
l'ingénierie nucléaire par exemple 6000
salariés en 2006 au moment où on
relançait
de nouveaux réacteurs notamment le PR 6
embauches
6 embauches sur 6000 salariés après on a
recommencé à embaucher très fortement au
début des années 2010
2014 de nouveau un coup d'arrêt alors
qu'on avait l'accident de Fukushima qui
est arrivé qui a imposé de nombreuses
modifications pour renforcer la sûreté
des tranches nucléaires et prendre en
charge tous les travaux et là comme
comme l'a dit Arnaud on est dans le
contexte de la PPE où on avait peu de
perspectives fallait perspective c'était
de fermer des tranches et donc là
la gestion des compétences et des
emplois c'était de dire on va avoir un
pic d'activité avec le poste Fukushima
mais comme on va à terme réduire la
charge et bien on va pas embaucher on va
traiter ça avec de la sous-traitance
donc là on a fait appel à un recours
massif à la sous-traitance pour passer
ce qu'on pensait être une vague sauf
qu'aujourd'hui on voit qu'il y a une
poursuite dans la dans la nécessité à
renforcer encore la sûreté sur le parc
existant à faire tous les travaux pour
le prolonger donc le grand carénage a
relancé
des réacteurs nouveaux en France et dans
le monde les petits réacteurs modulaires
voilà il faut le type de multitude de
projets et donc il y a très ce qui est
très important c'est aujourd'hui de
donner des perspectives pour avoir une
gestion long terme ça a été dit à
plusieurs reprises parce que c'est
vraiment ça aujourd'hui dans notre
industrie qui est primordial c'est
d'avoir cette gestion long terme entre
attractivité et fidélisation
juste là-dessus pour pour bien
comprendre vous dites qu'en 2010 il y a
une vague d'embauche que vous expliquez
par quoi dans la préoccupation de
l'entreprise à ce moment-là
il y a eu la il y a une vague il y avait
la relance du nucléaire dans le monde il
y a eu la même vague d'embauche chez nos
collègues d'Areva
donc c'était à l'époque chez AREVA on
pensait qu'il y aurait quatre pairs par
an qui allaient être construit donc il y
a eu très forte très forte embauches à
l'époque chez AREVA chez EDF et puis ça
s'est arrêté ça s'est arrêté rapidement
avec avec l'accident de Fukushima assez
simplement en fait et le gel du
nucléaire dans le monde
et puis il y a eu un phénomène il y a eu
une petite bouffée d'air à un moment
donné où ce qu'on a appelé le tutorat
parce que il y a eu le le une première
vague de départ en retraite avec un peu
d'anticipation mais le problème c'est
que ça s'est vite étouffé et que comme
Arnaud la précision on est sur des
métiers très longs en termes de
formation
d'appropriation et bien on se retrouve
dans une situation où
le phénomène qui est connu ailleurs dans
d'autres secteurs d'activité d'ailleurs
comment ça arriver c'est à dire le
phénomène de démission et
on il y a aujourd'hui à chalang énorme
pour l'avenir
alors de la filière nucléaire qui
dépasse le seul cadre de DF
entendons-nous mais le challenge il est
énorme là vous êtes en fin de débat
parlementaire sur la question de des
autorisations administratives et puis il
y aura la question du financement mais
même si on règle ces deux choses là il y
a un autre souci majeur c'est que pour
l'instant on n'a pas les bras et les
cerveaux c'est à dire que on est il y a
220 000 salariés aujourd'hui bon
l'estimation c'est qu'il faudrait 330
000 salariés pour répondre aux enjeux de
de
technologie de de mettre en place ces
nouveaux réacteurs alors on peut le
faire mais il faut un plan d'urgence
massif parce que ça veut dire qu'il
faudra passer par de l'immigration ça
veut dire qu'il faudra aller sinon
spoiler des secteurs entiers d'activités
en termes d'ingénierie parce qu'à cela
faut ajouter les départs en retraite
et on arrive à combien on arrive à une
facture de 380 000 il va falloir trouver
du monde donc bon enfin bon 180 000 en
embauche déjà sur 10 ans voilà et puis
on a on a souffert aussi d'un autre
phénomène au fil des années et qui s'est
accentué depuis le phénomène de
libéralisation c'est à dire que comme ça
a été géré encore une fois en boutique
il a été considéré que le premier
collège c'est à dire le collège
exécution ouvriers employé servait plus
à rien dans une entreprise comme EDF et
donc je suis à l'aise pour en parler
parce que j'en suis issu moi je suis un
je suis un pur produit de ce qu'on
appelait les écoles de métiers à
l'époque on rentrait à 17 ans dans
l'entreprise donc on rentrait tout en
bas de la grille mais on apprenait son
métier petit à petit et puis on était
oui avec fierté on prenait petit à petit
connaissances et savoir-faire et donc ça
ça a été abandonné fermé terminé donc ça
ça a aussi clôturé l'espoir pour des
générations entières de jeunes il y
avait plus l'affiche dans les dans les
lycées techniques ça a été vrai dans les
autres grandes entreprises c'est à dire
que toute cette filière de
l'apprentissage
avant le bac pour s'approprier la
technologie propre de l'entreprise et
c'est ça reste une technologie propre
les centrales aujourd'hui qui
fonctionnent fonctionnent sur des
technologies qui sont des années 80
voire 75 80 et ça ça peut pas
s'apprendre aujourd'hui dans l'éducation
nationale donc il y avait du sens à
maintenir ces écoles de métiers et en
parallèle de ça alors on est rentré dans
un système de pyramide inversée ou
finalement on n'est plus un encadrement
assis sur une maîtrise assise sur une
exécution c'est l'inverse donc on a une
entreprise 50% d'encadrement mais sauf
qu'en bas comme on a remplacé
l'exécution par de la sous-traitance
mais on sait plus qui fait quoi et à un
moment donné ça se paye ça se paye en
prolongation d'arrêt de tranche donc ça
coûte très cher à tout le monde et puis
ça se paye dans la
des disponibilités de la vision à long
terme et surtout ce qui est quand même
majeur c'est qui connaît aujourd'hui le
mieux les installations nucléaires du
péri voir hydraulique et baisse il y
aura un paquet de circuits il faut aller
voir les sous-traitants s'ils sont pas
partis en retraite ou s'ils sont aussi
ils ont pas changé de boîte et ça c'est
pas possible de continuer comme ça donc
là il faut taper à grande à grand coup
de poing sur la table et ré-ouvrir en
grand les vannes des emplois d'exécution
à EDF et ça on est évidemment on a bien
remarqué que dans la lettre de madame
borne au nouveau PDG ça ne figurerait
pas mais pourtant pourtant il faut il
faut absolument il faut absolument
insister là-dessus
dans votre propos liminaire vous vous
indiquez que vous avez formulé en 2017
une alerte sur l'incapacité Coré la
France à couvrir le pic de consommation
hivernale
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire plus
et notamment conjuguer ça peut-être avec
un regard critique sur les scénarios
de consommation électrique qui ont été
produits par les différents organismes
évidemment on pense à ceux qui sont
prescriptifs de RTE on peut penser aussi
à la façon d'alimenter la construction
de ces scénarios à l'époque et
aujourd'hui
je vais un peu développer donc oui la
consommation en électricité a été
dramatiquement sous-estimé ces dernières
décennies aujourd'hui on fait face à une
pénurie d'électricité et bien sûr les
conséquences économiques de cette
pénurie sont cinq communes aux yeux avec
une dimensionnement suffisante des
moyens de production pilotables donc
nous avec l'ensemble des représentants
du personnel qu'on a conduit des travaux
concernant des scénarios prospectifs
donc nous estimons que
les besoins en électricité décarbonée
justement pour assurer une économie de
carbonée à l'horizon 2050 sont plutôt de
l'ordre de 850 tirs à hauteur
c'est-à-dire 200 terawattheure de plus
que le scénario N3 du RTE
c'est aussi Corré par un certain nombre
de d'études au niveau européen toujours
sur sur ces questions là on peut
prospectives après je reviendrai sur des
éléments d'actualité beaucoup plus
concrets concernant le parc en
exploitation
cette transformation du système
électrique va s'opérer sur une trentaine
d'années et elle va concerner aussi les
réseaux de distribution et de transport
les investissements sont estimés autour
de 20 milliards par an elle s'effectuera
certainement dans un univers économique
et technique incertains en proie
notamment aux guerres pour l'accès aux
matières premières
c'est aussi fait l'objet des travaux que
vous conduisez depuis quelques mois nous
pensons que faire des choix responsables
c'est d'abord faire une évaluation
réaliste du moment à partir desquels ces
technologies pourrait intervenir à
grande échelle et on a pu vérifier
exactement que des scénarios 100% en
renouvelables demandent une
stabilisation donc des réseaux
électriques très décentralisés et sans
machine tournante et aujourd'hui ces
technologies ne sont pas encore matures
à l'échelle industrielle d'autres
éléments aussi interrogent sur la
résilience du tissu industriel à
conduire des travaux de grande ampleur
là je reçois aussi mes collègues qui ont
évoqué
le lancement d'un programme nucléaire vu
le dénoménagement des gouvernements
successifs en termes de politique
industrielle qui lui aussi de rendre
ampleur donc on a subi des
privilégiations des séparations des
activités verticales à l'intégrer donc
aujourd'hui les outils industriels qui
sont pour logiciel était construit sur
une moto le public qui ont permis à la
France d'avoir des émissions de CO2
faibles beaucoup plus faibles d'ailleurs
que la majorité des pays européens sont
aujourd'hui analysés comme des rentes et
des avantages concurrentiels
comme si leur pérennité et leur
efficacité à l'aide de soi or hors il y
a eu un certain nombre de liquidations
de ces atouts industriels je pense
notamment à Alstom Alex coin énergie
elle a été saccagée donc et même si et
nous avons tous pris position là dessus
que ça réintégration donc la branche
steam la branche nucléaire au sein de la
filière française ou européenne était
nécessaire pour préserver les
savoir-faire et les propriétés
industrielles autour de ce qu'on appelle
le groupe turbo alternateur c'est à dire
la turbine Arabel et
l'alternateur giga top pour autant le
rachat de la partie Steam de règles loin
sans faut un certain nombre de
difficultés concernant notamment
les brevets les savoir-faire en matière
aussi d'éolienechor la rénovation aussi
hydraulique on en a parlé les
concessions hydrauliques et leurs outils
les usines souffrent aussi d'un certain
nombre d'usures du matériel notamment du
sur prématuré lié aussi au suivi de
charges de marché donc on a aussi perdu
cette formation hydraulique qui a
toujours des tenues par les États-Unis
et aussi les grilles les grilles
concernant les transformateurs pour les
centrales et les réseaux
concernant toujours et je terminerai sur
la partie atom la partie nucléaire sur
la chaîne de valeur les tests analysées
aujourd'hui au 4 coins du monde et il
nous a même été
indiqués que dans le cadre du rachat de
Steam les fameuses turbines qui
pourraient être utiles pour demain se
doter de SMR pour être produite en Inde
donc ce sont des éléments
préfecture voilà on a des défis majeurs
c'est comment se dotent aussi d'outils
industriels robustes
du coup je reviens peut-être un tout
petit peu plus précisément sur ma
question sur les alertes quant à la
capacité à couvrir le pic et notamment
sur voilà la comparaison de vos alertes
par rapport au scénario au moment où
vous produisez ces alertes monsieur
Laplace
pour répondre à votre question ce que je
démontre nos travaux d'expertise menés
par le CESU central sur les passages de
l'hiver c'est que ces alertes sur la
sécurité d'approvisionnement elles ont
structurelles elles sont pas
conjoncturelles c'est à dire qu'il y a
eu le la crise sanitaire qui a obligé à
bouleverser les programmes d'arêtes
tranches sur le parc nucléaire pour les
trois prochains hivers il y a eu à gérer
le combustible après il y a eu la crise
technique de la corrosion sous
contrainte qui a
notamment touché
près d'une vingtaine de tranches
il y a la guerre en Ukraine qui pose des
questions d'approvisionnement en gaz il
y a le réchauffement climatique qu'il
était
comment dire réduit la capacité de
produire du nucléaire par le
lot pour refroidir l'eau des fleuves sur
la température ou le débit
qui atteint aussi le potentiel
d'hydrolicité mais ce que montre nos
travaux c'est que
tous les prochains hivers et même
peut-être même dans des saisons plus
douces voir l'été on aura des problèmes
on aura des risques de
d'approvisionnement électrique parce
qu'on a fermé 12 gigawatts de moyen de
production pilotable aujourd'hui en
France on est thermosensible donc ça
veut dire qu'on a 2,4 gigawatts par
degré dès que la température baisse d'un
degré ça nécessite 2,4 gigawatts de plus
donc si on ferme 12 gigawatts ça veut
dire qu'on réduit la marge de 4 degrés
5 5 degrés Celsius donc on a réduit la
marge pour passer l'hiver de 5 degrés
par rapport au moyenne tout simplement
et
alors je pose une question de néophyte
rTE est complètement indépendant mais
reste propriété de DF
bon
allez
le CSE du coup n'a rien à voir avec ce
qui se passait RTE on a absolument pas
de
nous on est représentants du personnel
de la de EDF et sa maison mère et il y a
c'est ce C au sein de au sein de RTE
messieurs sur les les nous regardons de
près évidemment les travaux de RTE
notamment tous ces bilans prévisionnels
au-delà des scénarios 2050 sur lesquels
nous avons fait une expertise
vous avez la synthèse de ce qu'on en
pense et on est quand même très critique
sur les travaux de RTE pendant des
années des années puisque pendant des
années des années RTE nous a dit tout va
bien madame la marquise vous inquiétez
pas est-ce que vous pouvez être un peu
précis sur le design et des années
disons que le dernier bilan prévisionnel
de
curieusement il tire la sonnette
d'alarme en disant ouh là là attention
il vous faire des efforts parce qu'on
n'est pas sûr de passer l'hiver un tiers
du rapport de RTE et consacré aux
mesures qu'il faut prendre pour
sécuriser le réseau en geste citoyen et
compagnie c'est qu'un incroyable alors
que toutes les années précédentes
RTE nous expliquait que il y avait pas
de il y avait pas de souci majeur on
pouvait fermer Fessenheim on pouvait
fermer les centrales thermiques RTE elle
est allé tirer du câble gérer des
interconnexions et mettre des onduleurs
et là nous ou nous on est très très
sévère c'est que vous parlez de
l'indépendance de RTE là pour le coup R2
et plus qu'indépendance ça revient nos
propos liminaires c'est à dire que qui
est en charge dans ce pays de la
prévision à long terme des moyens de
production à construire à mettre en
œuvre pour sécuriser l'approvisionnement
en tout cas c'est plus EDF donc EDF en
bon élève avec encore un peu de culture
de service public dit tiens bon on va
prévoir un plan de construction de 6 EPR
c'est pas son job c'est le job de RTL de
prévoir en principe mais R2 pendant des
années a dit que tout allait bien alors
on peut quand même se poser la question
majoritairement
RTE appartient à EDF
mais pas que donc rtea a des
actionnaires alors qu'est-ce que c'est
les actifs drte c'est du câble donc que
des que RTE finalement en boutiquier
comme les autres ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure en boutiquier RTE avait plutôt
intérêt à dire qu'il fallait faire des
interconnexions tirées du câble et
monter des onduleurs parce que ça
rentrait chez eux donc on voit il y a
tout un débat quand même aussi sur les
interconnexions ce qui RTE pendant très
longtemps a dit que les interconnexions
suffisait pour pour gérer la crise donc
on a parié sur quoi en fin de compte on
a parié sur les EnR et on a parié sur
les interconnexions autrement dit en
hiver vive le vent vive le vent d'hiver
et Petit Papa Noël parce qu'on n'est pas
sûr d'en avoir bon en été on n'a pas
trop de soleil on a vu aujourd'hui le
solaire ça n'a pas trop produire et à
19h on sait qu'on en a pas il fait nuit
donc on a on a joué sur le fait que de
dire enfin on nous a demandé de jouer
sur le fait que il y aura des
interconnexions donc on pouvait fermer
la centrale du Havre on pouvait fermer
Porcheville Aramon
[Musique]
on revient à l'équation de CM2 à
laquelle je faisais allusion tout à
l'heure moyen pilotable moyen pilotable
bon vous avez tous franchi le câble du
CM2 donc on peut y aller moyen pilotable
de production on additionne nos moyens
égal notre pic de consommation hivernale
aller 95 gigawatts au moins aller faut
viser 100 en France on ne l'a plus parce
qu'ils nous en manque 12 donc les
enfants vous avez vous êtes à moi 12 là
mais si vous avez toujours votre même
période de froid en hiver vous faites
comment et Arthur répond au contrat sur
les voisins mais la classe de CM2 aurait
dit non non il faut qu'on garde nos
moyens pilotables donc il faut qu'on
garde Fessenheim il faut qu'on garde du
thermique au moins le temps c'était le
bon sens qu'on apprenait le temps de
passer la longue série du grand carénage
sur le nucléaire on en avait pour une
bonne dizaine d'années on gardait nos
centrales thermiques et on était certain
de pas être dépendant c'est l'objet de
votre commission de pas être dépendant
des voisins ça n'empêche qu'évidemment
nous on défend le principe
d'interconnexion et de solidarité
d'échanges techniques et commerciaux
avec les voisins on n'a jamais produit
autre chose et sur l'interconnexion
d'ailleurs quand aujourd'hui on entend
certains qui nous disent ministre de
l'économie en tête que le marché
européen faut pas y toucher parce que
c'est grâce à lui qu'on a les
interconnexions l'interconner de les
interconnexions elles ont mon âge on est
né la même manière 67 ans Maastricht
c'est un peu après quand même donc
l'interconnexion on a su faire les
échanges de coopération en Europe niveau
technique pour tenir le réseau bien
avant cette sombre affaire finesse de
marché européen d'énergie donc RTE nous
on dit la responsabilité encore une fois
ce que je dis le marché lui il a fait
son job il a rendu le machin rares cher
je trouve que c'était électricité pas de
bol pour pour nous mais les autres rtea
gérer son affaire en boutiquier EDF à
gérer son affaire en boutiquier c'est le
cœur même du scandale de de pour lequel
on paye très cher la facture de cette
libéralisation du marché électricité
c'est que chacun ça a des responsabilisé
chacun il y a plus de vision globale du
service public de l'électricité qui gère
aujourd'hui en France le service public
de l'électricité il y a plus personne
alors c'est à vous madame monsieur le
députés de reprendre la main il y a plus
personne il y a des entreprises avec des
missions de service public
mais il y a plus personne qui a la
vision à long terme EDF propose des EPR
pourquoi parce qu'il faut aussi
s'occuper de la filière et c'est une
sacréation de servitude s'occuper de la
troisième filière industrielle de France
mais là la responsabilité de prévoir les
moyens de production pour répondre aux
besoins consommation du pays c'est RTE
donc là il y a aussi des choses qui vont
qui ne vont pas du tout du tout donc
voilà et juste pour terminer à la
réponse sur comment on va faire
peut-être parce que là on attirait cette
alarme mais vu le temps nécessaire à la
construction des nouveaux EPR vu les
ambitions fortes en décarbonation de
l'économie par l'électrification
véhicule électrique transfert d'usage et
autres
on va avoir un problème les hivers
prochains
pas seulement si agréable dans le
nucléaire je ferme ma parenthèse mais on
va avoir un problème les hivers
prochains c'est comment on va continuer
à répondre aux demandes en consommation
dans cette situation là alors on va
peut-être être dans une impasse terrible
on sera peut-être obligé de faire des
centrales à gaz les sites combines et
gaz parce que c'est le moyen de
production qui sort de terre en 18 mois
qui est le moins cher à construire
interdit aujourd'hui en France mais
comment on répond autrement qu'en étant
dépendant alors ça serait terrible parce
que c'est le combustible le plus le plus
cher aujourd'hui et en matière de des
responsabilisation puisque
chacun a géré sa crèmerie dans son coin
voilà en défendant les intérêts des
actionnaires pour aller vite
le marché lui en tout cas il a fait son
job mais en plus il s'est assis sur
l'accord de Paris et sur des rapports du
GIEC parce que le marché de
l'électricité en Europe depuis octobre
2021 il impose
par son système de mériteur il impose
que ce soit les centrales à charbon qui
tournent avec les centrales à gaz
le rapport c'est un peu plus de fois
deux
CO2 à l'atmosphère donc juste et je
laisse la parole aux rapporteur quand
vous émettez vos alertes sur le risque
de d'incapacité à couvrir le pic donc en
dès janvier 2017
comment c'est reçu donc à qui c'est émis
comment s'est reçu ce genre de choses
on a donc exorcé notre demande alerte en
tant que représentant du personnel au
travers de conférence de presse et de
travaux que nous avons rendu public et
depuis on a eu deux CS de dénoncer la
fermeture des 12 gigawatts de production
pilotable thermique et nucléaire qui
manque à l'appel et c'est 12 g c'est
exactement ce que le RTE indiquait là
entre l'hiver c'est ce qui va en curé
pour passer sereinement cet hiver
d'ailleurs et les hivers prochaine donc
on a vérifié les uns et les autres que
l'illusion que on était en surcapacité
d'électricité est terminée elle est
plutôt derrière nous maintenant cette
illusion et qu'on a des défis auxquels
il faut qu'on fasse face donc
notamment le parc nucléaire et le
service qu'il rend et qu'il rend je dois
dire dans des conditions de plus en plus
difficiles donc
soit vous avez quelques questions sur le
fonctionnement du parc pourquoi on en
est là aujourd'hui sur la baisse
tendancielle du productible si vous
voulez je peux développer un petit peu
le président pardon je vais je vais
venir à ces questions dans un instant et
je vous remercie déjà pour vos réponses
j'ai effectivement un certain nombre de
questions puisque nous avons eu le la
chance de dictionner avant vous les
responsables et en saint responsable de
DF et il y a une partie de ce que vous
nous avez expliqué qui correspond et
puis une partie qui est dissonante donc
ce sera intéressant de pouvoir avoir cet
échange au préalable je voudrais
simplement avoir une petite précision de
votre part sur deux aspects que vous
avez évoqué précédemment sur le fait que
RTU n'aurait pas émis les alertes que
vous avez évoquées alors que dès son
bilan prévisionnel de 2017 RTE parle de
l'hiver 22 23 et de l'hiver 23 24 comme
des passages difficiles avec des
chiffres qui ont l'air de correspondre à
ceux que vous donnez vous donnez et
deuxièmement pour comprendre pourquoi
vous vous indiquez que RTE aurait
dramatiquement je cite sous-estimé la
consommation d'électricité alors que les
prévisions de RT jusqu'à lors se sont
révélés juste à très peu à quelques
pourcentages près même si on peut
discuter de la les prévisions à long
terme
en 2017 ça va être dur en 2022-2023 on
se basant sur le planning du grand
carénage mais bon il s'est passé
quelques autres éléments entre deux
d'accord le covid et compagnie mais sauf
que RTE ne s'est jamais mis en
opposition cela fermeture de la centrale
de fée sodach ni cela fermeture des
moyens thermiques parce que RTE a visé
sur un taux de disponibilité des ENR et
un taux de disponibilité des
interconnexions qui à notre sens et
volontairement majoré ou de nature
extrêmement optimiste pour rester poli
donc effectivement c'est je reviens la
fameuse équation c'est à dire que RTE a
permis à la France de sortir de
l'équation
P égal C et le P pour nous c'est
l'ensemble des moyens
pilotables de capacité à installer en
moyenne pilotable il n'empêche
qu'évidemment quand on a dû renouvelable
on peut le prendre ça économise les
moyens pilotables l'eau pour
l'hydraulique l'uranium pour nucléaire
mais ça il faut le faire en complément
mais il faut toujours avoir son pic et
RTE par ces par ces bilans et par ses
prévisions à a permis
et c'est là que je m'attends que c'est
dramatique a permis à ce que la France
sorte du système qu'on appelait sur
capacitaire à une époque ou en tout cas
qui permettait d'entretenir les
centrales nucléaires sans la pression
absolue du marché comme tel que c'est
connu aujourd'hui et contrairement aux
Allemands parce que les Allemands à
l'heure où on se parle encore qui ont
développé les EnR beaucoup plus qu'en
France à ce jour les Allemands à l'heure
où on se parle on conservait un parc de
production pilotable qui couvre leur pic
hivernal sera assez pragmatique sur la
question
non c'est pas votre question mais c'est
c'est parce que j'allais dire c'est
parce que j'allais dire mais je sais pas
comment l'expliquer autrement
c'est-à-dire qu'on est sorti d'un cadre
dans lequel on était hyper sécurisé et
que nous il nous semble qu'en tout cas
de décideurs autorisés cela et comme la
responsabilité dans ce pays elle est
confiée et non à EDF
ce qui pose le problème d'accord on gère
les moyens de production EDF d'un autre
côté la vision à long terme nous on
pense que ça ça fait partie des effets
catastrophiques de déresponsabilisation
liées aux directives et à la
libéralisation du marché
si si on simplifie le débat à l'extrême
à l'ordre on a construit des centrales
nucléaires entre 77 et 94 à peu près
pour une durée de vie de 40 ans
on savait que c'est centrales allaient
s'arrêter donc en de 2017
etc donc on allait avoir un problème de
production parallèlement à ça on a une
tendance à l'électrification des besoins
donc qui à un moment donné qui réfléchit
sainement on peut dire on va électrifier
davantage de besoins donc on a des
scénarios qui partent sur une baisse de
la demande électrique enfin un moment
donné c'est pas cool je vous arrête
parce que c'est pas ma question ma
question c'est que vous avez dit que RTE
avait sous-estimé la consommation
d'électricité
ce n'est pas vrai
la consommation d'électricité telle
qu'elle a été prévue correspond jusque
là aux prévisions on peut avoir un débat
sur la suite de savoir si c'est
suffisant ou pas mais je voudrais juste
c'est un point de clarification tout
bête mais c'est juste pour être d'accord
alors dans l'équation juste alors si on
dit n'a pas sous-estimé la consommation
d'électricité alors je reprends le terme
de de l'équation à surestimer la
capacité de production pilotable
puisque l'équation est toujours du
cassée
effectivement que le président du
territoire en 2017 avait indiqué dans
une conférence de presse qu'on était
passé à un gigawatt de mesure
d'interruptibilité sur un réseau c'est
un événement voilà qui s'est passé suite
à ça quelle mesure aujourd'hui ont été
prises par les pouvoirs publics pour
pouvoir justement passer les hivers
c'est on va travailler mieux
certainement sur les contrats
d'effacement on a vérifié que les
contrats d'effacement savaient certaines
limites et il n'est pas exclu d'ailleurs
que sur les questions
d'efficacité énergétique de chasse
gaspillage et des envies de sobriété les
efforts s'accroisent justement pour
réduire la consommation et même il se
peut qu'on se dise qu'on n'est pas si
mal sorti sur le passage du cet hiver et
qu'on pousse encore les efforts de
sobriété auprès des populations
industrielles parce que on pourrait
faire mieux l'année prochaine mais ça on
arrive dans un cercle de récession
industrielle et sentiment de
déclassement que les usagers voilà
vérifient chacun notre quotidien donc
les pouvoirs publics en fonction de ces
alertes plus ou moins répétées entre le
RTE qui posait un certain nombre de
choses en disant on a des moyennes venir
et la réalité n'ont pas été suffisamment
suivi des faits
je vous remercie j'en viens aux
questions donc au point d'accord et de
désaccord enfin en tout cas de consensus
ou de non consensus avec les
déclarations des responsables SDF je
commence par les points qui me semblent
faire consensus je passe sur le premier
qui est la reine puisque vous avez les
uns et les autres ici et puis les
précédents responsables
estimez que que la reine enfin la
manière non seulement dont l'arène avait
été décidée puis le fait que la reine
n'avait pas été réévaluée
progressivement et qu'elle ne tenait pas
compte ni du coup du nucléaire existant
ni même du futur potentiel nouveau
nucléaire était un problème je voulais
quand même sur ce point vous interroger
sur la part vous l'avez vous avez déjà
commencé à le faire en parlant de la
mais sur la part que vous imputez à la
reine si je prends une déclaration de
Monsieur Proglio ou ensuite d'autres
responsables de DF certains ont été
jusqu'à dire que l'intégralité des
difficultés financières et de la
difficulté de capacité d'investissement
def venait de la reine je voulais avoir
votre sentiment sur ce point
c'est
nous nos estimations que c'est un tiers
de la dette
un bon 15 milliards donc c'est un bon
tiers de la dette alors ce qui est
certain c'est que les autres tiers c'est
les dividendes et les aventures
internationales donc si on est deux
autres tiers il y a un levier c'est à
dire on prend les dividendes ou pas et
on va à l'international faire les malins
ou pas tandis que la reine il n'y a pas
de levier donc c'est un truc quand même
pérenne dans le temps enfin jusqu'à 2025
et qui est qui est oui
insupportable puisqu'il il en plus il a
enfin la loi normale on devait il devait
profiter au démarrage pour amorcer la
pompe des concurrents pour les voir se
lancer dans les moyens de production on
devait voilà et puis on devait voir
l'innovation donc en fait on a rien vu
du tout ou très peu on a en capacité de
production ils ont rien fait les
concurrents ils ont tapé dans l'arène
pour faire du beurre et par contre en
innovation bon on a vu ils ont mis tout
leur plateau réponse aux clients à
l'étranger dans les pays francophones à
bas coût du travail et puis ils ont
fabriquer des centaines de milliers de
personnes dans les cages escaliers alors
faire signer un truc vite fait vite fait
sur le bout du sur le bout de la table
de la cuisine c'est ça l'innovation des
concurrents en matière de donc on a vu
la loi Nome merci donc on demande son
abrogation immédiate évidemment après
vous soulignez que c'est un point de
convergence avec la direction
certes mais jusqu'à un certain point
puisque nous je le redis on demande la
suspension de la reine et que cette
proposition de suspension n'est pas
reprise par la direction de l'entreprise
je vous remercie un autre point de
convergence même si il est aussi discuté
c'est celui des compétences et vous avez
évoqué le fait que l'attractivité des
métiers aurait été fortement réduite du
fait de l'annonce d'un plafond en valeur
enfin en volume et en pourcentage du mix
électrique de la production nucléaire et
puis que la fermeture prévue de tranches
avec un impact mais vous avez aussi
expliqué vous avez parlé madame de du
nombre d'emplois supprimés dans la
période précédente et vous avez aussi
évoqué le pas de temps de recrutement et
de compétences la question que
j'aimerais vous poser c'est avant
les annonces qui ont pu et qui ont dû
avoir un impact sur les compétences et
la capacité à recruter il y a bien eu
est-ce qu'il n'y a pas eu selon vous un
effet de d'attractivité inférieure avant
même cette cette question d'annonce du
futur réacteur est-ce que selon vous le
management de chez EDF a une
responsabilité en la matière est-ce que
selon vous il a pris les mesures pour
attirer les compétences les talents
formés
ce métier là est-ce que c'est pour le
dire autrement uniquement la faute de la
décision politique de ne pas avoir
construit précédemment davantage de
réacteurs dans une période comme je
reprends votre expression parce qu'elle
est particulièrement saillante de
dilution sur capacitaire ou est-ce que
selon vous le management d'EDF par le
passé à failli partiellement totalement
dans sa capacité à attirer à recruter
des compétences
en effet il y a de multiples raisons
mais le management d'EDF a pour vraiment
une grande part de responsabilité dans
ce manque d'attractivité
des salariés pour venir à EDF puisque
comme je vous l'ai dit à partir du
moment où EDF devient sa il faut
optimiser la masse salariale donc ça
passe par un pilotage très cadré de tout
ce qui est mesure salariale et à partir
de ce moment là on assiste à un
décrochage des salaires de l'entreprise
par rapport à d'autres industries et
puis je parle pas d'une comparaison avec
d'autres domaines qui peuvent être des
services ou les banques donc les
salariés veulent majoritairement aller
dans les domaines les plus rémunérateurs
et en effet on a pâtit de de se pilotage
qui a généré une réalité salariale qui a
duré pendant des années et que nous
avons bien du mal à rattraper pour faire
face aux défis technologiques qui nous
attendent on a aussi souffert donc comme
comme on dit mes collègues
de Fukushima et des conséquences en
suite sur l'image du nucléaire
les jeunes salariés ont envie d'avoir
un travail
en lien avec leurs aspirations un
travail qui a du sens et quand on subit
du nucléaire bashing pendant des années
ça n'aide pas à attirer les talents
autre chose également
on a subi en plus de cette optimisation
de la masse salariale des plans
d'austérité budgétaires à tous les
niveaux donc on a des salaires qui ont
décroché
par rapport à l'attractivité du domaine
industriel mais on a aussi comme l'ont
dit mes collègues des projets
industriels qui ne se sont pas faits des
Stop and Go et donc tout ça fait que
c'est très compliqué pour embaucher et
pour donner envie à des salariés de nous
rejoindre
quand vous dites des salaires qui ont
décroché est-ce que vous pouvez être un
peu plus précis
alors c'est c'est le salaire et le
modèle social d'EDF dans sa globalité
je vous cache pas qu'aujourd'hui on est
encore attaqué sur notre régime spécial
mais ce régime spécial il a une histoire
et et il est lié à la spécificité de
l'électricité qui est un besoin
essentiel pour notre pays on ne peut pas
s'en passer donc il a fallu construire
le parc et maintenant il faut le
maintenir maintenant il faut construire
de nouveaux moyens de production donc
nous avons besoin de rester attractif et
quand vous êtes avant le passage en et
ça eu un épique vous avez des salaires
qui sont inférieurs par rapport à des
sociétés privées vous avez une grille
des salaires et vous avez une évolution
de salaire qui peut être plus lente que
dans une entreprise privée mais tout
cela était lié à un package social qui
fait que finalement à la fin de par le
régime spécial de retraite et bien vous
retrouver avec une situation qui est
intéressante mais le l'évolution de
carrière à EDF et lente par rapport à ce
qui peut ce qu'on peut connaître dans
une entreprise privée et c'est vrai que
ces dernières années comme le curseur
était sur l'austérité salariale maximum
et que
notamment le président Lévin c'est pas
caché du fait qu'il voulait se
débarrasser de notre grille de
rémunération pour la remplacer par des
choses plus ou moins baroques et bien ça
n'a pas aidé à comment dire à développer
l'attractivité de notre de notre
entreprise puisque on a un système qui
doit être irrigué par des augmentations
négociées dans les mesures salariales
mais si vous n'y régiez plus votre
système et bien ça ne tourne plus et on
a pu constater ces cinq six dernières
années un phénomène de démission que
nous ne connaissions pas alors des
démissions 200 300 à l'année c'est plus
faible en comparaison avec les autres
entreprises mais c'est un phénomène qui
n'existait pas avant et que nous avons
maintenant chaque année des démissions
parce que des jeunes salariés des
salariés qui ont des compétences
stratégiques partent pour manque
d'attractivité des salaires EDF
si je peux me permettre d'apporter un
complément sur ce point-là donc vous
l'avez sans doute compris les salaires
d'embauche sont fixés par une grille
dans l'entreprise et donc c'est comme
les fonctionnaires on peut réactualiser
on peut réactualiser le point d'indice
en quelque sorte ce qui fait évoluer les
salaires d'embaucher donc si on compare
par rapport aux années 95 ou 2000 un
ingénieur ou un technicien qui embauché
avec un diplôme donné il rentre dans un
niveau dans la grille et le problème de
la grille c'est qu'elle n'a pas été
revalorisée au même niveau que
l'inflation mais avec quand même un
décrochage certain alors c'est pareil
dans les autres entreprises mais il
suffit que le delta soit inférieur dans
les autres entreprises à EDF on peut
penser que enfin il faut sortir il
faudrait sortir des chiffres très précis
mais on estime que à partir des années
2000 on a un décrochage de la grille des
salaires par rapport à l'inflation de
l'ordre de 15%. donc quand vous
embauchez un ingénieur dans les années
dans les années 2000 ou un technicien il
avait plutôt en salaire d'embauche dans
l'entreprise EDF il trouvait un salaire
d'embauche attractif par rapport aux
autres
[Musique]
il va se retrouver avec un salaire
inférieur donc en fait
ça crée un véritable problème et le fait
de ne pas rehausser suffisamment la
grille des salaires par rapport à la
concurrence des autres entreprises fait
que vous rendrez financièrement les
emplois à EDF moins attractifs et donc
c'est évidemment il n'y a pas que ça que
regarde et c'est encore heureux que les
jeunes embauchés regardent autre chose
que le salaire mais enfin ça fait quand
même partie des éléments fondamental
quand vous acceptez un emploi
la que vous avez soulevé
les prix de marché aujourd'hui ne
reflètent pas les véritables coûts de
production et des investissements futurs
donc on peut même dire que le nouveau de
rémunération des activités de l'ensemble
des activités d'EDF et bas il est
insuffisant il est aussi peu
représentatif de l'ensemble des services
qu'on rend au système électrique donc
dans la même période de libéralisation
du secteur de l'énergie on a vu
offensive sans précédent contre
Électricité de France contre ces
motivations et même sa structure on est
allé même jusqu'au pillage pur et simple
avec la reine et dans ce contexte les
dirigeants d'EDF ont géré les affaires
courantes comme une autre entreprise et
gérer les affaires courantes c'est avant
tout ne pas mettre trop d'argent sur les
effectifs et les investissements utiles
pour l'avenir et quand on met pas trop
d'argent sur ces effectifs et sur les
investissements utiles pour l'avenir on
en met pas assez
la zone de Maine aussi capitalistique
que l'énergie la fortiori le nucléaire
les conséquences ne sont pas visibles de
manière immédiate elle se voyent sur
plus long terme et aujourd'hui on est
rattrapé par la patrouille qui conduit à
toutes les difficultés que nous
rencontrons sur l'ensemble des parts de
production et pouvoir assurer une
mission de service public
si je peux compléter
vous nous demandez si selon nous il y a
des responsabilités de l'employeur
au-delà des décisions politiques
il y en a au moins deux qui limitent
l'attractivité des emplois de notre
entreprise et le recours massif à la
sous-traitance qui a conduit à une perte
d'intérêt du travail c'est-à-dire que
les aujourd'hui les les techniciens
les salariés PDF sont en surveillance
des prestataires et ne sont plus dans la
prennent plus les gestes et il y en a un
certain nombre de gens qui qui expriment
une certaine lassitude par rapport à
cette perte d'intérêt du travail
il y a également des changements de
modèle d'activité
un certain moment quand la comment dire
quand le contexte
qui était décrit de société anonyme dans
un modèle beaucoup plus concurrentiel on
rentre sur des activités qui sont
exposées à la concurrence et donc où la
masse salariale devient le levier
principal de
pilotage de l'activité et c'est aller
jusqu'à des activités comme le nouveau
nucléaire
ou pour maintenir la filière comme il
n'y avait pas de projet en France on est
parti à l'international mais avec un
nouveau modèle d'activité c'est à dire
qu'on ne construit plus des centrales
pour les exploiter on est plus en
exploitant de
centrales nucléaire on vient comme
vendeur d'études c'est-à-dire qu'on est
même plus dans le
commissionning la mise en service ni la
construction on vient juste apporter des
études des plans détaillés et là donc
c'est plus la maîtrise du coût du projet
qui est le facteur principal c'est le
taux horaire et donc c'est pour ça c'est
ce que Catherine on est arrivé à des
modèles on a filialisé avec des
conventions collectives
moins socialement moins 10 ans pour
abaisser ce taux horaire et pour être
plus compétitif mais sur un marché qui
n'était pas celui de DF à la base donc
ça oui aujourd'hui quand on sur ces deux
sujets là quand on en parle avec nos
directions aujourd'hui nous entendre
notamment sur recours à la
sous-traitance ils nous disent qu'ils
veulent réinternaliser un certain nombre
d'activités mais on pense que le braquet
est pas encore assez important et par
contre sur l'aspect finalisation que ça
soit dans l'ingénierie hydraulique ou
dans l'ingénieur inucléaire là
aujourd'hui on n'est pas encore entendu
sur les petits réacteurs modulaires qui
démarrent on vient de créer une filiale
en convention collective Syntec pour un
projet qui est d'avenir donc c'est pas
des ingénieurs EDF qui ont été embauchés
comme ça on juge quelque part qui sont
pas assez bons pour faire ça et donc ça
ça pose des problèmes aux salariés
aujourd'hui qui est notamment de
fidélisation
je vous remercie j'en viens à un point
qui s'entraire là j'espère la pensée des
responsables de DF semblent un peu plus
faire des accords c'est celui des
situations actuelles
et du point de vue de la maintenance
notamment l'idée selon laquelle la
situation actuelle serait due à un
concours de circonstance
le covid et le décalage
subséquent d'un certain nombre de
maintenance de la maintenance d'une part
et d'autre part du grand carénage
et puis la corrosion sous contrainte qui
est un défaut générique qui n'était pas
prévu et probablement prévisible en tout
cas de à ce stade
ce que j'ai un petit peu de mal à
comprendre c'est que quand bien même on
annonce l'arrêt de tranche
progressif enfin la fermeture de
tranches progressive et quand on est à
la direction d'une telle entreprise on a
un actif industriel et donc y compris
d'un point de vue de rentabilité
économique au-delà même des aspects de
l'investissement quand vous avez parlé
il s'agit de l'entretenir et d'en
assurer la continuité et j'allais dire
le niveau de productible puisque vous
vous en parliez tout à l'heure et vous
parliez d'une baisse tendance de
productive on peut aussi de productible
on peut aussi s'interroger sur le
planning du grand carénage et sur le
fait qu'il y a une forme de simultanéité
qui est particulièrement fâcheuse quand
en plus il y a une crise énergétique et
des retards biocovid donc je voulais
avoir votre avis sur l'évolution du
productible ces dernières décennies que
selon vous ça traduit des choix
techniques industriels et managériaux de
la direction et puis et puis sur sur la
capacité à mieux anticiper ces
différents points selon vous
je vais je vais pas répondre sur la
totalité mais en partie alors c'est
clair que le covid a désorganisé
profondément l'activité du parc donc ça
c'est une évidence
sur grand carénage ce que
les pourquoi en fait on
les patrons de dev décident de faire
grand carénage d'une part c'est pour
prolonger la durée de vie des centrale
et deuxièmement c'est parce qu'on a un
contexte réglementaire en France qui
oblige à
développer les meilleures technologies
et de moderniser sans arrêt nos
centrales nucléaires
et ça ça génère des dépenses et des
travaux puisque enfin dépenser de
l'argent c'est des travaux ou des
travaux c'est des pensées de l'argent
comme vous voulez qui sont énormes et ça
c'est des choix je suis pas si on peut
qualifier ça de choix politiques ou
choix administratif ou choix de société
mais c'est c'est des choix qui
n'existent pas par exemple vont vous
prenez un exploitant américain ça
centrale elle a 80 ans il a remplacé les
composants dont la durée de vie ne
permettait pas d'atteindre cet âge-là
par contre la centrale qui a 80 ans j'ai
visité la sorte centrale de turc époint
en Floride la salle des machines à l'air
libre il y a même pas de toi parce que
ça a été construit à 80 il y a 60 ans ou
50 ans c'était vu comme ça comme Novial
centrale thermique on avait les machines
à l'air libre ça ne posait de problème à
personne et la centrale est toujours
comme ça aujourd'hui parce que ça donc
on a en plus de les contraintes
techniques ou administratives
qui sont mis sur l'entreprise
quelque part ont un poids et sont à
l'origine des d'une partie du travail
colossal qu'on est obligé de faire sur
grand carénage et donc oui ça bah
quelque part ça ça a un impact sur le
productible parce que pour faire des
travaux il faut rendre les tranches
indisponibles et donc qui diront des
tranches indisponible dit moins de
production d'électricité donc ça
n'excuse certainement pas tout des
dirigeants de def mais quelque part ils
sont bien obligés de d'appliquer les les
principes et les directives et qui
s'imposent à eux d'une certaine façon
alors sur notre prestation différente
l'analyse des situations du parc avec
des directions on pourra toujours dire
que la crise du covid a été imprévisible
de même d'ailleurs que les phénomènes de
crosion sous contrainte qui sont
apparues pourtant on a vérifié qu'il y
avait des dérives qui étaient visibles
identifiables ou bien entendu maintenant
quelques années on avait conduit une
première expertise en 2016 voilà sur sur
la baisse du cahier du coefficient de
disponibilité qui a été actualisé au
sein du CSC il y a maintenant quelques
mois donc
comment on peut se l'expliquer c'est que
sur le parc du production il faut
toujours produire plus et le mieux
possible alors que nous sommes dans un
champ de contrainte qui est différent de
ce qu'il était encore il y a quelques
années il est de plus en plus difficile
d'absorber les variations de production
intermittentes certaines emporteront
l'appeler au rang donc incontrôlable de
plus en plus parce qu'il y a un taux de
prédatation des on-r intermittent de
plus en plus important et en parallèle
on lâche suffisant lundi le parc
thermique et réduit à peau de chagrin
elle part thermique permettait en termes
de boutique de production d'être plus
adapté sur ce suivi de charge le parc
nucléaire français l'a fait c'est celui
de charge et le fera sans doute encore
mais ces contraintes elles sont sévères
il y a les effets de saisonnalité qui
sont de plus en plus importants il y a
des difficultés à mettre en oeuvre le
programme de maintenant on en a parlé et
une aggravation aussi depuis le covid on
la vérifier ce qui a affecté notamment
les équipes d'intervention la
bouleverser les plannings c'est ce qu'on
appelle le curé annuel qui doit être
visité
donc on peut dire que le bon
fonctionnement du système électrique
reporte désormais de plus en plus sur le
parc nucléaire et ça part dans les
moyens de production pilotable
d'ailleurs ne cesse d'augmenter ça c'est
paradoxal mais on voit effectivement
que ce phénomène aussi n'a pas été
suffisamment
anticiper et d'ailleurs
rémunéré en tout état de cause à fur et
à mesure que le rôle du parc nucléaire
s'accroît donc nous pensons qu'il faut
désormais engager une meilleure gestion
de ce qu'on appelle les arrêts pour
maintenance en termes d'entretien et
aussi de contenu des activités et
surtout s'y tenir parce que les enjeux
de prolongation des durées de vie du
parc actuel sont ici corrolées à ces
activités de maintenance
alors sur les activités de maintenance
et la gestion des arrêts on l'a fait
pendant plusieurs décennies s'y tenir
sur sur ces contenus des activités mais
ça a été aussi progressivement perdu
aussi sur les faits de la dégradation du
tissu industriel et qui renvoie aussi à
la dégradation des compétences n'a pas
assez parlé mais pour apprendre à faire
il faut faire des compétences c'est
quelque chose de vivant ça de rebondir
quand on n'a pas suffisamment
d'activités alors sur nucléaire neuf sur
Leclerc un exploitation
on n'a pas la possibilité de transmettre
un certain nombre de compétences
pratiques c'est pour ça aussi que nous
le disons nous n'aurons jamais assez il
faut recruter il faut recruter
rapidement pour pouvoir anticiper les
défis qui sont devant nous juste sur
l'augmentation aussi des volumes
d'activité sur le parc en exploitation
il y a aussi des exigences en parallèle
accrues en matière de sûreté parce que
ça a été dit peut-être dans d'autres
dans d'autres auditions
elles sont pas neutres ça fait partie
aussi une amélioration continue de la
sûreté il y a aussi une augmentation on
l'a dit des contraintes liées au Sud
mais aussi au suivi des besoins du
marché ça c'est un élément nouveau et
que nous bien sûr dans le cadre du
service public et de la sortie
de l'électricité de marchandise de
première nécessité nous mettons en avant
dernier point
concernant le personnel il faut prendre
des mesures des mesures d'urgence pour
personnel parce qu'il on a besoin
de redonner du sens au travail on a des
beaucoup développé la question des
besoins recrutement de formation de
stabilité aussi des équipes on en a
c'est pas assez parlé en étant arrêt
dans des bouleversements des
réorganisations incessantes dans les
différents collectifs de travail il faut
aussi donner de la visibilité chez les
sous-traitants en engageant des contrats
de plus leur terme et dans les affiches
et bien sûr sur les plannings
d'intervention il faut qu'il soit
sécurisés le mieux possible et les
arrêts de tranche il faut qu'il cessent
d'être une variable d'ajustement par
rapport aux disponibilités du parc
dernier point parce que j'ai on a
largement développé sur les compétences
oui il faut recruter dans les collèges
exécutions et maîtrise parce qu'on a
besoin de recréer des viviers pratiques
de compétences et ça ça permettra aussi
de retrouver une certaine maîtrise
industrielle au sein d'EDF
rapidement mais très rapide
par rapport à l'anticipation préparation
de l'avenir par rapport notamment quand
sous contrainte aujourd'hui un des
enjeux pour l'entreprise c'est de créer
un moyen de contrôle non destructif pas
obligé de couper pour voir si la
corrosion
et donc ça ça passe pas de la recherche
développement et ça c'est un autre point
de désaccord qu'on a avec notre
direction c'est l'affaiblissement de la
R&D avec des fait ça avec une intensité
des investissements R&D par rapport au
chiffre d'affaires qui est inférieur à
celle de d'autres électriciens
comparables en Europe et c'est quelque
chose que sur lequel on alerte
l'affaiblissement de la R&D
juste un moule là-dessus sur commande a
fait pour en arriver là et à pas prévoir
c'est un peu votre le sens de votre
question
on sait que quand on arrête des tranches
avec le vieillissement au fil du temps
un arrêt va pas faire l'autre et que de
toute façon on va avoir des retards et
que par expérience on savait que ça
allait être plus compliqué sur d'autres
tranches et c'est la vie c'est la vie de
l'industrie ce sont des machines qui
vieillissent donc c'est tout à fait tout
à fait logique et c'est pour ça je
reviens là-dessus que les 12 GW il nous
manque beaucoup parce que 12 GW c'est
directeur nucléaire en moyenne donc si
on prend 91300 il nous manque énormément
et parce que quand vous si votre
garagiste il la voiture je regarde trois
semaines au garage vous vendez pas la
seconde c'est pas le moment et ben là
c'est pareil on allait avoir de la
maintenance c'était pas le moment de se
débarrasser des autres moyens de
production encore une fois la
déresponsabilisation de la direction de
l'entreprise à se dire bah je gère avec
ma colonne dépense profit et voilà en
boutiquier et pas de vision de de long
terme mais c'est eux qui c'est vraiment
j'accentue aussi c'est le cœur du
problème qui aurait dû regarder ce
problème d'ailleurs RTE ou EDF je remets
une couche c'est c'est c'est c'est
criant en terme de qui est responsable
de quoi
allez on va faire tourner un peu la
parole de notre côté monsieur jumelles
puisque c'est vous qui les souhaitez
cette table ronde merci président
d'abord moi-même je souhaite remercier
les organisations syndicales parce que
ils viennent nourrir par leur expertise
leur intelligence les travaux de la
commission et c'est utile pour nous
d'avoir cette éclairage là
faudra peut-être d'ailleurs président
compléter cette audition par l'audition
de Jean-Pierre Soturac a été désigné par
les organisations syndicales comme étant
susceptibles de nous éclairer encore
plus précisément sur les enjeux qui
touchent à notre commission d'enquête
j'ai deux ou trois questions l'enjeu de
la commission d'enquête
c'est d'abord de nous éclairer sur quels
sont les décisions politiques ou de
gouvernance d'entreprise qui ont conduit
à affaiblir notre souveraineté
énergétique moi je pense que c'est
important de savoir quels sont les
moments clés y compris les responsables
politiques qui ont pris des décisions de
nature à
affaiblir cette souveraineté énergétique
non pas pour simplement régler des
comptes mais pour ne pas renouveler les
erreurs du passé ça c'est le premier
sujet donc moi j'aimerais savoir
si je vous conseille d'administration il
y a des procès-verbaux de conseils
d'administration à quel moment clé vous
identifiez tout ce que vous avez
expliqué
centrale thermique du AF Fessenheim
absence d'investissement fermeture des
écoles de métiers aussi qu'aux
substantielles à la question de
renouvellement de savoir-faire etc et
puis deuxième sujet l'objet de la
commission d'enquête c'est de savoir
quels sont les leviers pour recouvrer de
la souveraineté énergétique de ce point
de vue ça m'intéresse d'avoir votre avis
sur plusieurs sujets est-ce qu'il suffit
que l'État soit actionnaire même à 100%
pour avoir un état stratège un état
planificateur un état
qui répond à nos questions première
question
deuxième
sujet donc que faut-il
y compris comme outil de gouvernance
comme outil démocratique pour se doter
d'outils publics de nature à permettre
cette politique énergétique
troisième sujet pour ne pas faire trop
long
croyez-vous que l'affaiblissement de nos
souveraineté énergétique qui a eu des
conséquences sur la souveraineté
industrielle tout court je partage cet
avis réside aussi dans
la mise en miette de l'unicité de
l'outil de politique énergétique
et donc de ce qu'on affaiblissement a
mené une politique globale et cohérente
et puis enfin vous l'avez Fleuré mais
vous pouvez vous le préciser un peu plus
selon vous est-ce que le statut des
électriciens gaziers c'est mon avis mais
j'aimerais avoir le vôtre et qu'au
substantiel à
une garantie de souveraineté parce que
le statut va de pair avec un haut niveau
de qualification
de compétences et même de neutralité
dans des secteurs aussi stratégiques
quel est votre avis là-dessus
est-ce que les tatisations à 100% je
commence par par celle-là mais on va se
partager des réponses mais
on vient de vivre une étatisation et pas
une nationalisation par OPA donc nous on
nous nous sommes les héritiers de la loi
de nationalisation 1946
dictée par Marcel Paul donc évidemment
et qui le faut qu'il l'a mise en oeuvre
en application du Conseil national de
résistance et là on a une une
étatisation par européen dictée par des
banques d'affaires donc on n'est pas
tout à fait sur les mêmes repères mais
nous on assume les nôtres et donc
évidemment c'est pas la même chose
nous nous souhaitons une loi de
nationalisation devant le Parlement
devant vous devant la représentation
nationale afin de fixer les moyens et
objectifs du service public de
l'électricité et d'en suivre les effets
et conséquences dans le temps surtout
d'avoir ce suivi également
or on en est très loin évidemment et on
en est tellement loin qu'aujourd'hui les
informations sont délivrées au marché
avant de vous être délivré ou d'être
délivrés représentants du personnel sur
les tranches arrêtées sur voilà le
productible voilà tout est c'est le
marché qui a les informations en premier
lieu donc on souhaite une loi de
nationalisation qui ne suffirait pas
d'ailleurs en elle-même parce qu'il faut
une loi de nationalisation qui précise
aussi la gouvernance de l'entreprise
et pour nous la gouvernance des
entreprises c'est pas un conseil
d'administration
chargée de régler des affaires et des
bonnes affaires tant qu'on y est puisque
ce qui intéresse surtout c'est
déplacements internationaux le tri
qu'est-ce qui rapporte en trois ans etc
non c'est pas ça c'est d'abord une
vision du service public donc la
représentation nationale la reprise
tentation des
usagers par association de consommateurs
notamment et la représentation des
salariés c'était d'ailleurs le modèle
qui était proposé en 1946 donc ça ça
aurait vraiment du sens et donc là on
serait très loin d'un conseil
d'administration confiné chargé de voir
comment on fait des affaires des
affaires à court terme
quitte à accentuer la dette alors qu'on
investit pas dans les moyens de
production donc ça serait un élément du
triptyque que l'on propose les deux
autres éléments c'est la sortie du
marché de l'électricité
parce que reprendre la souveraineté
énergétique on l'a abordé tout à l'heure
c'est sortir du marché de l'électricité
c'est maîtriser les tarifs par son mix
de production nationale et c'est
sécurisé l'approvisionnement donc ça
c'est le deuxième évidemment c'est
arrêter le dogme de la de la concurrence
dites libre non fossé mais c'est du
foutage de gueule en ce qui concerne
l'électricité chacun le sait bien et je
reprendrai des propos de de François
Carlier d'ailleurs de l'association de
consommateurs CV qui dit c'est plus
besoin de faire un référendum sur est-ce
qu'il faut la concurrence dans
l'électricité puisque 90% des
usagers clients sont revenus sans
revenus chez EDF tout le monde a compris
les méfaits du marché électricité je
note que les collectivités locales
aujourd'hui sont toutes à demander le
retour au tarif réglementé électricité
et c'est un scandale qu'elle n'y est pas
accès et les entreprises également donc
voilà je crois que les tous projets de
loi nationalisation qui prendra en
compte ce nous mettons sur la table
serait plus que de bon ton serait
moderne et tout à fait dans l'actualité
il est urgent que le pays reprenne la
main par les représentants de la nation
reprennent la main sur une asservice
public tel que celui de l'électricité et
je dirais même plus globalement de
l'énergie
c'est la question du statut
alors dans notre histoire le la loi de
nosseignation c'est le 8 avril 46 et le
statut c'est le 22 juin 46 alors bon il
y avait certainement un esprit de
cohérence et effectivement c'est
intéressant parce qu'on vient d'aborder
la question des compétences sur le long
terme et comment ça a été dit par mes
camarades comment nous faisons en sorte
de maintenir l'attractivité
quand on regarde
rapidement et on a la chance à la CGT
d'avoir un bel institut d'histoire
sociale et dont la devise est connaît de
le passé pour comprendre le présent à
préparer l'avenir et on regarde comment
ce statut est apparu et bien à l'époque
Marcel Paul et ses camarades collègues
qu'est-ce qu'ils font ils observent que
pour avoir ça suffisait pas la loi
nationalisation il fallait avoir la main
d'oeuvre et la main d'oeuvre quand on
remet l'état la nation debout parce
qu'il y a rien la France est exempt on a
la sortie de la guerre bah la main
d'oeuvre elle part prioritairement dans
le elle part dans le bâtiment elle part
dans sur des gros chantiers elle est pas
elle est pas disponible pour
l'électrification pour monter le réseau
et pour aller sur les gros chantiers
en ingénierie et à la main d'oeuvre de
l'hydroélectricité notamment et du
thermique le statut vient aussi de là
bien sûr des acquis d'avant gars de la
construction parce que il fallait
consolider attirer et fidéliser les
salariés et ben on est en plein dedans
c'est-à-dire que aujourd'hui avec le
chantier qu'on a devant nous on sait
même pas où on va trouver ces 180 000
qui va falloir trouver oui la question
du statut de la garantie collective
forte de haut niveau elle est
parfaitement posée et elle est même
indispensable alors évidemment comme on
est un peu à contre-courant ces jours-ci
sur cette question là et on l'a souligné
à plusieurs reprises dans nos dans
l'audition
l'inquiétude ne fait que s'accentuer oui
ça accordait indispensable mission de
service public si on veut de nouveau
parler de service public et pas
seulement de mission de service public
donc il faut montrer ce service public
je vais je vais laisser sur la troisième
question peut-être mes camarades juste
sur le qui fait quoi alors on
l'adressait rapidement tout à l'heure
qui a fait quoi c'est les directives
alors après c'est la grande question du
procès d'intention ou pas mais en tout
cas il y a évidemment des responsables
derrière
les premières directives c'est 96
celle-là elle ouvre le principe de la
concurrence
elle casse beaucoup beaucoup de choses
et puis ensuite on a
2004 on a Barcelone en 2002
je dirais que Jospin qui vont prendre un
sangria avec Aznar Blair et Berlusconi
et là ça tourne mal pour nous puisque
c'est le ils appellent ça la l'étape
finale de la marchandisation du gaz
électricité ça c'est catastrophique un
élément catastrophique qui a bien
d'incidence deux ans après Sarkozy ouvre
le capital
d'EDF et Gaz de France la main sur le
cœur ici meuble en disant que jamais Gaz
de France serait privatisé d'ailleurs on
sait qu'aujourd'hui Gaz de France a
totalement disparu dans la question de
se pose plus de 6 7 engagements étaient
tenus ou pas et puis et puis on a
évidemment la loi Nome qui vient
corroborer tout ça en continuant de
spolier nos services publics au profit
des intérêts privés
scandale qui est toujours d'actualité si
vous y mettez pas phase jusqu'à 2025
donc on l'a on est dans la pure apologie
du libéralisme c'est comment on se sert
les services publics pour rincer les
intérêts privés donc EDF depuis
46 à connu deux périodes formidables une
de 50 ans de monopole public au service
du pays et une de libéralisation où elle
a été fragilisée pied spolier et où elle
est de moins en moins capacité de
répondre à ces enjeux de service public
je vous ai mis dans les pochettes vous
verrez la courbe de la dette avec un
repère important 2004 quand on devient
société anonyme là vous voyez la dette
elle a été très importante à un moment
donné quand on construit le parc
nucléaire
là on monte à 62 milliards alors c'est
tout ramener en constant et puis là
ensuite on baissait la dette et puis là
on remonte on multiplie par 3 et là
quand on parle de déresponsabilisation
bah là c'est tout le enfin c'est c'est
tout les paris internationaux et des
cadeaux aux copains via la reine via ce
que ce qui a été dit aussi la
sous-traitance pour faire plaisir à des
copains qui venaient prendre dans les
caisses enfin voilà on a le patronage je
dois dire a été assez imaginatif entre
filialisation maintenant d'aller
startups qui qui sont en projet sur les
nouveaux nucléaires modulables ou autres
alors bon bah le on a du mal à imaginer
que au sein des startups des salariés
vont rester plus de 15 ans voir 20 ans
ou 25 ans
voilà on est c'est-à-dire que ça c'est
une vraie question c'est comment on
maintient dans le temps des gens dont la
fonction est d'assurer le service public
de l'électricité de la construction à
l'exploit jusqu'au démantèlement
désinstallation en passant par la
commercialisation les fonctions supports
d'ingénierie mais sans garantie
collective de haut niveau c'est l'échec
assuré
par ajout des grandes choses donc ça
fait 25 ans maintenant que la dérailleur
de la
délibération du secteur après la
maîtrise publique du secteur et ça a
dégradé aussi notre souveraineté
énergétique ça fait 25 ans aussi que les
personnels sont des personnels et des
salariés subissent les conséquences au
quotidien etc réglementation on a
beaucoup parlé d'emplois de conditions
de travail et surtout de sens au travail
aussi et ça je pense que pas non plus
sous-estimer c'est pas pareil quand on
travaille pour des missions de service
public au service de la nation que quand
on travaille effectivement pour une
entreprise lambda qui fait de
l'électricité ou des baskets ou bien
d'autres choses donc attention aussi au
sens du travail je pense qu'il faut pas
non plus sous-estimer la charge
symbolique que ça représente donc moment
clé on a su faire d'en assurer réussir
de grands projets industriels et
notamment le plan Messmer qui est encore
reconnu comme un succès industriel le
plus grand succès industriel j'ai 41
dernières années grâce aussi à
l’étricien publique nationale et son
personnel statutaire Julien développé
tout à l'heure que il y a une
fidélisation latente de l'ingénierie au
sein de EDF et notamment ceux qui ont en
charge la conception de l'Union
nucléaire donc pour nous c'est un point
d'alerte sérieux puisque ça revêt des
questions aussi de responsabilité en
tant qu'exploitant mais aussi concepteur
des centrales nucléaires donc sur ces
questions là mais sur nous sommes
il y a même un opposé à cette
dégradation
des conditions statutaires de ces
personnels pour justement conserver ses
prorogatives au sein de l'entreprise
publique et je partage pleinement que la
propriété capitalistique des entreprises
ça suffit pas assurer cette maîtrise
publique il faut bien sûr assurer
rassurer effectivement de maîtrise par
les citoyens des missions et des
orientations des entreprises mais aussi
renforcer les problés du personnel on
l'a déjà dit à plusieurs reprises on a
exercé nos devoirs d'alertes sur la
question des moyennes de production
pilotables et les risques de pénurie
plus fort de l'hiver mais pas que on est
aussi effectué des devoirs et des droits
d'alerte sur les questions économiques
et qu'il nous semble essentiel donc les
droits d'intervention des salariés
soient aussi renforcés ça aurait évité
aussi bien des déboires on l'a pas
suffisamment évoqué peut-être dans le
cadre de cette Commission concernant le
père de Flamenville depuis 2006 on a
alerté de manière continue sur la tenue
des plannings sur l'état des capacités
industrielles sur les moyens qui étaient
dédiés aussi à la réussite de le père on
a été pas suffisamment entendu
malheureusement on aurait peut-être pas
pu éviter
un certain nombre de dérives
on a aussi je pense que que Philippe qui
est du CNPE de Flamanville alerté aussi
sur les questions sociales sur sur le
chantier et notamment alerté sur le
génie civiliste c'est un porté comme un
voyou qui a été condamné dernièrement
Bouygues pour travail dissimulé
puisqu'il a employé des salariés
détachés et puis il a été condamné
définitivement maintenant il y a
quelques mois on a été seul la CGT
apporter à ces sujets là sur la place
publique et nous semble qu'en termes
aussi d'acceptibilité sociale aux
propriétés
jumelles qui a un chantier conséquent
peut-être devant lui sur sur le site de
paris sûrement c'est ce que bien sûr
nous espérons pour redresser y compris
la situation industrielle du pays c'est
des sujets qui ne sera pas possible de
reconduire si on veut engager réussir le
lancement du programme nucléaire
il y a peut-être un sujet qu'on n'a pas
totalement abordé c'est le côté
entreprise intégré en quoi est-ce
important d'avoir une entreprise
intégrée alors je vais essayer de
l'illustrer au travers d'exemples assez
simples vous avez une centrale
hydraulique une centrale nucléaire et
des énergies renouvelables sur un marché
un moment donné si vous possédez
l'ensemble de ces moyens vous êtes en
capacité de les optimiser et de
réfléchir aux moyens et long terme sur
par exemple l'usure de votre centrale
nucléaire est-ce que ça vaut le coup
d'arrêter votre centrale 12 heures
toutes les 24 heures pour laisser la
place pendant l'été à de l'énergie
photovoltaïque c'est pas forcément
évident parce que vous allez
mettre plus de produits chimiques pour
réguler votre réaction nucléaire vous
allez user votre votre
usine prématurément enfin c'est comme si
vous utilisez une voiture en ville ou si
vous utilisez une voiture sur
l'autoroute l'usure de la voiture n'est
pas la même donc le coût économique
après de votre maintenance sur la
centrale ne sera pas les mêmes et pareil
si vous avez une centrale hydraulique
vous avez une centrale hydraulique en
amont d'une centrale nucléaire alors
qu'est-ce que vous faites vous turbinez
de l'eau pas cher parce que ça permet le
refroidissement de la centrale nucléaire
plus bas ou finalement vous arrêtez
votre centrale parce que vous gardez
votre énergie pour plus tard quand le
marché sera un prix plus élevé pour
vendre vos électricité au prix le plus
fort sachant qu'en faisant ça bah
potentiellement vous allez obliger la
centrale nucléaire en aval a baisser sa
production parce qu'elle aura pas
suffisamment d'eau pour être refroidie
si vous avez un opérateur intégré
l'optimum économique globale de son
marché et dans ses mains et donc
forcément il va chercher à optimiser les
choses si vous morcelez les producteurs
sur le territoire c'est optimisation
vous l'avez pas et à l'extrême la
meilleure optimisation ça serait d'avoir
un producteur européen quelque part
déjà on a un marché français suffisant
ça vaut le coup de se concentrer sur la
France on peut faire de belles choses
c'est une belle ouverture si créer de
nouveaux débats
merci monsieur le Président et merci
pour vos propos et pour vous expliquer
très éclairantes mais question j'ai deux
questions qui portent sur deux sujets
liés aux salariés de DF la première est
liée à la formation des salariés vous
avez beaucoup parlé du nombre de
salariés qu'il fallait recruter dans les
années à venir
sur les compétences dans les différents
directeurs au président directeurs
généraux d'EDF qu'on a auditionné ces
derniers jours ou ces dernières semaines
que j'étais soit présent soit que
j'écoutais en différé en visio il y a eu
un gros axe développé sur les types de
compétences qui étaient nécessaires pour
réhabiliter relancer la production des
centrales est-ce que vous pouvez nous
préciser quels sont selon vous les
compétences particulièrement critiques
et les métiers particulièrement
critiques on entend beaucoup parler des
métiers de soudage de chaudronnerie de
maintenance dans l'électricité et ce que
vous en avez identifié d'autres et en ce
sens c'est ce que vous pouvez nous dire
un petit mot de ce que vous pensez du
projet de l'Université du nucléaire
ma deuxième question porte sur le moral
des salariés d'EDF il y a un indicateur
il me semble-t-il en interne qui est qui
est assez distinctif en ce sens c'est le
baromètre my EDF a-t-il été publié ces
derniers jours pour un récapitulatif de
2022 en ce sens il me paraissait
éclairant temps sur le moral actuel des
salariés tant sur la situation actuelle
que sur la confiance qu'ils ont dans
l'avenir de l'entreprise et l'avenir du
secteur si vous avez accès à ces
chiffres qui ont déjà été publiés
pouvez-vous nous les commenter et nous
en donner un bref aperçu merci
sur les compétences les différents types
de compétences la filière nucléaire
beaucoup travaillé sur un certain nombre
de secteurs vous les avez cités ce sont
surtout les opérateurs de première ligne
l'auteur d'une heure soudeur aussi
indiquer la question des projecteurs des
usineurs aussi alors à la fois un nombre
il faut recruter un nombre mais aussi ce
qui est aussi préoccupant pour nous
c'est que dans les 10 ans la moitié est
peut-être certainement plus aussi dans
certains métiers de profondeur notamment
il y aura moins de la moitié des
fondeurs qui seront présents donc c'est
pour ça qu'il y a urgence à recruter
pour anticiper et transmettre ses
compétences mais ça suffit pas on est
sur une filière industrielle et quand on
veut relancer travailler effectivement
sur la construction de réacteur nouveau
le premier secteur qui intervient c'est
le génie civil et on a trop vu sur le
père de Flamanville alors faut en parler
de territoire mais aussi un peu imputer
ou génissiviste Bouygues environ deux
ans de retard et le génie civil au-delà
de ça donne le la pour le reste du
chantier donc ça nous paraît extrêmement
important de pas sous-estimer c'est ces
secteurs qui sont souvent mis dans
l'ombre de la filière nucléaire et
d'autant que ce sont des métiers
extrêmement pénibles et que pour
travailler justement sur la question de
l'attractivité permettre aussi à des
jeunes de venir il faut travailler sur
la reconnaissance notamment la
reconnaissance technique des métiers
leur valorisation il n'y aura pas de
façon d'industrie
2.0
il va falloir aussi voilà réactiver
revitaliser le tissu industriel mais
aussi permettre d'avoir des aciéries des
fonderies alors on n'a pas parlé sur
l'affaire de corrosion sous contrainte
mais en termes d'indépendance ou un
thème énergétique on était obligé
d'aller chercher effectivement des
pièces qui étaient
alors c'était pas si loin de nous en
Italie mais si t'as pas été non plus
aussi convenu que cela a pu paraître
donc ce sont des sujets majeurs nous
semble-t-il concernant les défis qui
sont devant nous et qui font un tout
quoi on peut pas s'attaquer à un aspect
du problème sans regarder l'ensemble le
traiter
en complément je reviens sur un point
qui qui est super important c'est donc
Virginie a bien identifié les les
métiers qui qui nous font défaut
aujourd'hui et faut pas oublier ceux qui
vont nous faire défaut demain si encore
une fois on change le
statut des IEG ou le système de retraite
car il a un avantage énorme aujourd'hui
c'est la fidélisation des ressources et
donc pour former un opérateur sur le
nucléaire il faut plusieurs années un
bon opérateur c'est au bout d'une
dizaine d'années d'expérience et un très
bon opérateur c'est 15 à 20 ans
d'expérience donc s'il part à ce
moment-là c'est vraiment une grosse
grosse perte pour l'entreprise et dans
les métiers de maintenance c'est la même
chose un bon électricien ou un bon
automaticien comment l'a dit tout à
l'heure aujourd'hui dans nos centrales
on a des technologies qui datent des
années 75 et où des années les plus
modernes 90
dans les écoles personne ne forme sur
ces technologies là donc c'est bien
quand ils rentrent dans l'entreprise qui
commence à se former et pour qu'il soit
autonome pour qu'il soit en capacité
d'intervenir d'astreinte un dimanche
après-midi il faut qu'il connaisse une
l'ensemble des matériels de la centrale
et donc ça ça demande des une dizaine
d'années à minimum pour former un très
bon automaticien qui soit autonome en
central nucléaire donc c'est fondamental
quand vous l'avez formé de le garder
dans l'industrie nucléaire et c'est pour
ça qu'un statut attractif c'est la seule
façon de fidéliser finalement vos sinon
bah c'est c'est on se crée demain enfin
en modifiant des paramètres du statut on
se crée demain des problèmes qu'on n'a
pas aujourd'hui
sur la question du moral des troupes
alors moi je vais pas commenter un outil
de management qui s'appelle
effectivement maillot EDF dont on a pas
alors on se parle il doit être en cours
de en cours de
dépouillement
écriture peut-être je sais pas ce qu'il
y a derrière la boîte noire comme tout
donc voilà mais en tout cas ce qui est
certain c'est que vu des organisations
syndicales le personnel d'EDF il est
lucide surtout sur la situation dans
laquelle l'entreprise se trouve sur le
la le gros problème de la spoliation via
la reine sur le problème du marché la
concurrence et sur ces problèmes de
conditions de travail
quotidiennes qui le préoccupe aussi
parce que à beaucoup d'endroits on est
en on est en surcharge de travail sur
les exploitations parce qu'il faut
remettre des tranches sur le réseau donc
d'autres il faut les maintenir sur
l'activité commerciale on reprend à peu
près 100.000 clients par mois bon on n'a
pas un plus donc vous imaginez les
conditions de travail et ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'il est à la fois lucide et
qu'il a quand même la patate parce que
ça fait quatre ans maintenant qu'on est
en uneanimité syndicale sur tous les
sujets et ça c'est pas rien on pourrait
dire chapeau monsieur Davy finalement et
ça c'est pas rien et parce que et il est
il est surtout acteur de victoire
majeures la première c'est d'avoir mis
Hercule par terre qui était le plan de
désintégration de l'entreprise et
d'ouverture d'un certain nombre
d'activités au capitaux privés et ça
c'est quelque chose qui le porte
fièrement était un groupe le personnel
derrière ces quatre organisations
syndicales représentatives et puis
également une bagarre plus interne mais
sur la sur les salaires ou là aussi
il a obtenu gain de cause voici quelques
semaines donc
après avoir gagné deux matchs aussi
importants vous pensez bien qu'il est en
forme pour le troisième s'il se présente
et à partir de dans 48 heures on va
pouvoir mesurer son état d'esprit mais
le personnel il est il est lucide avec
les inquiétudes quand elle a pérennité
de l'entreprise parce que tout va
dépendre des et votre les travaux de
votre commission bâtissent finalement
enfin on le souhaite baptis les projets
d'avenir autour du service public
d'électricité mais comme on nous dit
avec raison que l'avenir est électrique
le personnel d'EDF il est pas dans
l'état d'esprit de
[Applaudissements]
qui a pu connaître le personnel de chez
Kodak au moment où on est passé du de
l'argentique au numérique vous voyez
c'est l'inverse donc on nous dit on nous
dit que finalement l'avenir a été
électrique donc on a pour des décennies
et sans doute des centaines d'années de
bonheur et comme par hasard c'est aussi
le créneau que choisissent beaucoup pour
ouvrir les capitaux et privatiser les
activités parce que l'ensemble des
sociétés d'électricité de la planète si
l'avenir est électrique bah après faut
faire un choix soit c'est dans une
sphère publique et de gestion publique
de cette affaire avec des cercles qui
peuvent être vertueux
d'auto-investissement de finalement
d'investissement aussi dans les autres
services publics ça ça c'est quelque
chose qui aurait plus que du sens ou
alors est-ce que cet avenir électrique
il va aller dans la poche de certains et
dans les porte-monnaies d'intérêt privé
et là on est au carrefour des choix mais
en tout cas quand on dit dans un secteur
d'activité que l'avenir est électrique
vous pensez bien qu'en principe
ça doit tirer vers le haut mais pour
tirer vers le haut il faut encore avoir
les bras les cerveaux les garanties
collectives et puis une vision d'avenir
qui soit claire et qui soit si possible
orienter vers le service public donc
redonner du sens en plus au travail ce
que les jeunes va se faire beaucoup
environnement sans au travail voilà donc
nous on a tout pour on a tout pour
réussir mais
vous allez les choix vous appartiennent
en fin de compte les choix vous
appartiennent et reprenez la main et
redonnez-nous du sens en mettant ça dans
le cadre d'un service public intégré et
là je pense que vous aurez du succès
non mais c'est un complément sur la
question du moral des troupes si je peux
dire les discours récurrents qui ont
consisté à demander toujours des efforts
supplémentaires ou personnels ont montré
de sérieuses limites on est on a subi
différents plans d'économie alors
certains s'appellent en mimosa il y en a
toujours en cours il faut que ça cesse
passer à autre chose
et être beaucoup plus en rapport avec
les défis qui sont encore d'avenir en
demandant donc maintenant il va falloir
prendre comme le disait Philippe
leur des choix on est à la croisée des
chemins donc
soit on s'engage et nous à la CGT on est
capable donc de s'engager des techniques
gamins sur un aveugle lumière décarboné
pour l'industrie et pour assurer aussi
l'indépendance énergétique de la nation
mais il faut mesurer que la pente est
raide pour redresser la situation et que
les taux sont inscrire aussi dans la
durée donc soit on jette le manche après
la cogner parce que c'est très difficile
et qu'on peut assez
assez facilement prendre certaines
raccourcis soit on se retrouve sur les
manches je pense que sur ces sujets là
on pourra y compris trouver avec les
directions d'EDF les parlementaires et
aussi l'ensemble des parties prenantes
des points qui vont nous permettre
définitivement d'avancer
merci monsieur le Président
tout d'abord je tiens vraiment à vous
remercier pour d'avoir exposé du point
de vue effectivement du salariat d'EDF
et bien les les raisons de cette perte
d'indépendance électrique du pays qui
bien évidemment sont indissociables et
bien de l'histoire récentes et de ce
beau groupe qui est EDF
près de 20 à 30 ans finalement de
décision des gouvernements successifs
avec la régulation européenne et
l'instauration notamment de la reine qui
ont conduit à détricoter l'un des
fleurons nationaux de ce pays l'un des
leaders mondiaux d'ailleurs de
l'électricité ce qui est assez paradoxal
aujourd'hui alors même que on ne cesse
de parler à juste titre donc des enjeux
des objectifs de lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique quel paradoxe
effectivement que ces gouvernements qui
nous ont dirigés ces dernières années
aujourd'hui on se retrouve effectivement
à subir une pénurie d'électricité vous
en avez parlé à te voir subir une
politique de sobriété qui est une
stratégie en réalité de gestion de
pénurie digne d'un pays du tiers-monde
et qui ont clairement pu être évité si
comme vous l'avez dit nous avions
conservé
à minima durant la durée effectivement
du grand carénage nos capacités de
production pilotables
également nous avons subi une perte de
savoir-faire qui aujourd'hui il faut pas
se mentir menace l'avenir de la filière
nucléaire puisqu'il faut la retrouver
donc pour essayer de retrouver
effectivement cette sécurité
d'approvisionnement électrique du pays
ça passera évidemment par le groupe EDF
faut pas se mentir vous l'avez dit ils
sont vraiment vous vous questionner sur
l'avenir du groupe donc le projet
Hercule qui visait à démanteler le
groupe en trois entités et notamment en
ouvrir deux au moins au capitaux privés
à semble-t-il été abandonné
quid de son projet alternatif
ma question est la suivante madame la
Première ministre a à charger le nouveau
PDG du groupe et exemple de faire une
proposition dans les six mois donc avant
l'été pour structurer le groupe EDF
est-ce que vous de votre point de vue
vous avez
vent de ce qui pourrait être envisagé en
termes de préconisations quelles sont
les démarches qui ont été entreprises au
sein du groupe pour que vous puissiez
être associé puisque si je ne me trompe
pas de mémoire la première ministre
demande à ce que les parties prenantes
soient associés donc dans quelle mesure
serez-vous associé puisque je ne vous
cache pas qu'à mes yeux et au nom du
groupe rassemblement national que je
représente la vision que vous nous avez
exposé là et globalement c'est le que
nous défendrons également
et par ailleurs donc vous avez on en a
un peu discuté mais vous avez longuement
évoqué effectivement les difficultés
qu'impliquent et bien finalement
l'abandon progressif de tout un tas
d'activités par le groupe EDF notamment
vis-à-vis de certaines compétences liées
à la maintenance et à la construction de
centrales qu'elles sont nucléaires ou
hydrauliques par exemple est-ce que
selon vous la nouvelle direction d'EDF
envisage justement au regard de du
nouveau feu vert qui a été donné pour
construire de nouvelles centrales
nucléaires envisage d'aller vers une
stratégie de réintégration de ces
activités ou bien envisage de poursuivre
dans la lignée de ces dernières années
avec le recours de sous-traitant qui
peuvent conduire à des cas malheureux
comme malheureusement le le père de
Flamanville en témoigne je vous remercie
alors premièrement de réponse c'est que
la première ministre effectivement
mandaté le nouveau PDG sur un certain
nombre de thèmes et justement de de
remettre son état de réflexion je crois
avant l'été bon nous on est associé à
rien en l'état actuel des choses mais
c'est pas une surprise puisqu'on n'a
jamais été associé à rien du temps de
d'Hercule puisque ce d'ailleurs Hercule
c'est intéressant puisque il y a une une
garantie par par le le gouvernement dans
le document de l'offre publique de
rachat que Hercule n'était plus à
l'ordre du jour mais enfin Hercule
officiellement avant n'était pas l'heure
du jour parce que le dossier soi-disant
jamais existé donc nous Hercule
on avait les briques d'information par
la presse essentiellement et
effectivement c'est tout ce montage
envisagé de désengage de l'entreprise et
les bradage au privé des parties les
plus rentables à court terme
a fait l'objet surtout de discussions en
coulisses dans les souterrains ou dans
les dans les couloirs entre le Président
de la République
des gens à Bruxelles non
identifié à part la
commissaire de la de la commission la
concurrence et puis et puis le le
PDG sortant donc nous pour nous c'est
cette histoire c'est du passé parce que
on
considère qu'on a emporté la victoire
nous sommes quand même parfaitement lui
c'est des vigilants on peut avoir un
match retour avec une possibilité de
retour un de vos collègues députés
branlent à évoqué il y a quelques jours
de d'avoir cette possibilité d'un
Hercule qui sera encore dans les cartons
ou d'un ou d'un autre nom grec peu
importe les repères mythologiques mais
qui est certain c'est que encore une
fois on est à l'heure des choix donc
les représentants de la nation à notre
sens ne peuvent pas laisser faire la
désintégration de la boutique et je dis
boutique à dessin parce que à l'heure
actuelle c'est une boutique donc il faut
en refaire un service public c'est ça
c'est ça l'enjeu et donc
tant que ça a pas changé le PDG qui
vient d'arriver il va gérer ça comme un
boutiquier donc s'il faut faire trouver
du beurre pour telle ou telle activité
et qui il n'y a pas de solution et de
vision à long terme d'un service public
qui ferait comme avant c'est-à-dire
avoir la capacité à construire son parc
nucléaire remboursé sur les factures au
fil du temps parce que c'est ça c'est et
auparavant le parc hydraulique
tout à l'heure parce qu'on faisait
référence aux dates en 1960 46 la
nationalisation 1960 56 % de la
production est hydraulique et puis on
arrive sauf que en 73 on est dépendant à
75% du pétrole parce que la demande a
augmenté qu'il a fallu faire des
centrales essentiellement au fioul et
en très peu de temps finalement c'est
pour ça que les les
choix en matière énergétique dans le
pays ils ont été faits avec audace en
général et rapidité la loi de 46 service
public Marcel Paul Bam Bam en 6 mois
c'est bottley le plan Messmer en 6 mois
c'est bottley c'est à dire que et là on
s'affranchit et en 20 ans on construit
56 réacteurs nucléaires en 20 ans on
construit 56 réacteurs nucléaires
aujourd'hui en 15 on n'arrive pas à en
faire donc il faut se poser des
questions sur notre capacité à faire et
on le faisait avec
donc on a dit tout à l'heure les
capacités ouvrières à faire et
d'ingénieurs à faire donc voilà c'est
soit on laisse EDF gérer comme une
boutique et alors il se passera ce qui
se passera et on continuera à avoir des
projets alimentés par les banques
d'affaires
c'est un grand risque un grand risque
avec la bénédiction bruxelloise soit
la nation reprend la main la nation
reprend la main sur les questions
énergétiques et sur le service public de
l'électricité on peut considérer que
c'est une parenthèse malheureuse qu'on a
vécue puisqu'on a eu je redis 50 ans de
monopole publique donc on parle pas du
utopie on parle de quelque chose qui a
existé moi j'ai fait la moitié de ma
carrière professionnelle dans le cadre
du monopole public d'EDF sur 394 dans la
maison donc voilà c'est pas utopique on
a on a ça c'est pour ça qu'on insiste
aussi sur la question du double bilan et
aucun gouvernement jusqu'à présent nous
a répondu positivement le double bilan
c'est à dire le bilan de 50 ans de
monopole publique de service public
quelle réussite comment maîtriser les
prix quel retour des collectivités
locales des entreprises des citoyens
usagées de ce pays et que et comment on
compare ça au bilan des 25 dernières
années
pour reprendre une expression kodakienne
il n'y aurait pas photo un autre avis ce
président il y aurait pas photo donc
faisant faisons ce double bilan c'est un
exercice qu'il faut mener et
je pense que là encore une fois les
boutiques qui soit il reste des
boutiques et avec les meilleurs lettres
de de mission du monde mais ils vont
avoir des intérêts divergents entre les
différentes entreprises énergies c'est
aussi très mauvais pour le pays des
intérêts divergents parce que des
intérêts pour pour
ce qui seront dictés par leur
actionnaires même s'il leur actionnaire
est 100% état aujourd'hui l'État c'est
pas la nation donc c'est c'est c'est
vraiment l'heure des choix je réponds je
réponds comme ça à votre question
est-ce que quelqu'un veut compléter
ce qui est en train de question
écouter si c'est alors je vous en prie
pour répondre sur
la volonté de déesse
de
réinternaliser les compétences qui sont
sous-traitées oui on nous dit qu'il y a
cette volonté actuellement donc c'est
plutôt une bonne chose EDF
mais des moyens pour essayer d'attirer
ces profils sur les compétences clés qui
nous manquent
voilà donc maintenant nous on ne demande
qu'à voir mais cette volonté on nous dit
que c'est maintenant une des priorités
d'EDF de réinternaliser au maximum les
compétences dont nous avons besoin pour
pour faire face aux défis industriels de
demain donc
nous pensons enfin avoir été entendu sur
ce point maintenant reste à voir si ce
sera possible
pour compléter ce que nous dire
Catherine non seulement la question de
du curseur du fer du fer faire faire de
l'entreprise c'est un sujet tabou et on
a malgré nos demandes réitérer d'avoir
effectivement un échange serein avec la
direction sur nos besoins pour justement
que service maîtrise technique et
industriels ça nous a été refusé il y a
d'autres aussi contre signaux qui sont
donnés au sein d'entreprise sur la
question de de la maîtrise de la
réinternalisation tout à l'heure Julien
le soulevait c'est la question de la R&D
la R&D permet d'anticiper et de traiter
certains nombre de difficultés qu'on a
rencontré sur les parquets enfin
d'ailleurs parce que nucléaire on peut
parler aussi alors de ce qu'on appelle
les tas de force donc ce sont des des
équipes qui se mettent ensemble dans
différentes entités du de l'entreprise
que ce soit en recherche que ce soit un
Ingénierie Nucléaire et hydraulique et
elles ont permis de faire face à
certaines événements on a beaucoup parlé
de corrigions sous contrainte c'est
aussi comme ça qu'on a pu développer un
outil performant de contrôle non
destructif qui demande désormais être
qualifiée mais aussi on a pu traiter des
phénomènes d'apparition des dépôts aussi
sur les crayons combustibles sur
l'incendie etc or après cette année
consécutive de baisse dans les effectifs
en a supprimé près de trois départements
à la R&D
c'est parfaitement inacceptable et
dernièrement nous venons d'apprendre
alors les les représentants et les
salariés d'arrêter qu'on va fermer aussi
les boucles d'essai concernant la
robinetterie en fait dans le domaine de
la remontérite qui permet de qualifier
certains matériels ce sont des pertes de
connaissance dans ce domaine qui sont
indispensables autant sur le parc
d'exploitation que sur le Pr sans ces
outils internes EDF sera dépendant donc
d'installation inter-extérieur la
conséquence c'est aussi qu'elle devra
diffuser
à l'extérieur des infos confidentielles
et attendre aussi les disponibilités de
ces moyens d'essai donc c'est payer plus
cher pour avoir moins bien et sans avoir
une certaine sécurité donc c'est ça
aussi les comptes signaux qui nous sont
donnés en tant que salarié représentant
du personnel
merci beaucoup
Mesdames et Messieurs les élus membres
du comité social et économique central
je crois que cette audition nous a été
utile là aussi pour amener un angle
supplémentaire à notre lecture on fera
la même chose avec les centrales
énergies des différentes organisations
représentatives ce qui permettrait
d'élargir un peu le spectre mais ça nous
semblait important plus spécifiquement
concernant EDF puisque
bien que 63% du mix énergétique français
ne soit pas électrique
quand on parle de politique énergétique
on parle souvent de politique électrique
puisque finalement il y a ce sentiment
des Français que et des politiques que
DF est quand même encore leur outil même
si même si la nature juridique a pu
évoluer
l'actionnariat principal de DF
toujours resté public aujourd'hui est
totalement public il donne ce sentiment
finalement on a au moins un moyen d'agir
alors que sur le reste du champ
énergétique le moyen d'agir est moins
direct
ce qui n'est pas forcément
en matière de compréhension de l'ampleur
du débat énergétique une bonne chose on
s'entende pas que on dispose de moyens
d'agir sur l'électricité mais que on se
focalise sur la seule électricité même
si je suis convaincu je pense que le
rapporteur partagé avec moi
du caractère
essentiel de l'électricité dans les dans
les années qui viennent pour pour notre
nation je vous remercie très sincèrement
pour votre disponibilité pour vos
réponses le ton de l'échange et je vous
souhaite une belle soirée